Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. The Tsar is a man of very hot temper, soon inflamed and very brutal in his passion. He raises his natural heat by drinking much brandy, which he rectified himself with great application. He is subject to convulsive motions all over his body, and his head seems to be afflicted with these. He was desirous to understand our doctrine.
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告版节目、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。沙皇脾气非常暴躁，一点就着，发起火来十分残暴。他通过大量饮用烈酒来激发内心的火气，这些烈酒都是他自己非常刻苦地蒸馏出来的。他全身都有抽搐的毛病，头部似乎也饱受这种病痛的折磨。他渴望了解我们的教义。
He was indeed resolved to encourage learning and to polish his people by sending some of them to travel in other countries and to draw strangers to come and live among them. He seemed apprehensive still of his sister's intrigues. After I had seen him often and had conversed much with him, I could not but adore the depth of the providence of God that had raised up such a furious man to so absolute authority over so great a part of the world. So there we have Scotsman Dominic. Yeah. You could tell from my magnificent impression of a Scotsman.
他的确决心振兴文化教育，通过派人到其他国家游历并吸引陌生人来此定居来使他的国民变得文明。他似乎仍然对姐姐的阴谋诡异感到忧心忡忡。在我多次见到他并与他进行了深入交谈之后，我不得不由衷赞叹上帝天意的深邃，正是这双手将这样一个狂暴之人推上了如此绝对的权位，让他统治了世界上如此广阔的土地。所以，这就是我们的苏格兰人多米尼克。是的。从我那对苏格兰人的精彩模仿中就能看出来。
Yeah. And I called Gilbert Burnett who met with Peter the great in London in 1698, but by far the most significant and interesting thing about Gilbert Burnett is that he was the bishop of Salisbury. He was. And how wonderful it is. We are doing this series about Peter the Great, who we left as master of Moscow. He'd crushed his sister Sophia's resistance. He'd secured the loyalty of the Streltsy, these frankly sinister and faintly grotesque soldiers who wear yellow boots and calf-downs and who
没错。我提到了吉尔伯特·伯内特（Gilbert Burnett），他于1698年在伦敦会见了彼得大帝，但关于吉尔伯特·伯内特最重要、最有趣的事情是，他曾是索尔兹伯里的主教。他确实是。这是一件多么奇妙的事啊。我们正在制作关于彼得大帝的系列节目，上期节目中我们讲到他成为了莫斯科的主人。他粉碎了他姐姐索菲亚的反抗，赢得了斯特列利茨军（Streltsy）的效忠——这支军队坦率说来令人毛骨悚然、怪诞不经，他们穿着黄色靴子和小牛皮靴，而且
have a great fondness for jumping on the body parts of people that they've chopped and sliced into little bits. But here he is in England. He's twitching uncontrollably. He's drinking brandy. He's chatting about Protestant doctrine and he's doing it with a man from my neck of the woods, from Wiltshire, from Salisbury. From the Salisbury area?
特别喜欢踩在那些被他们剁成碎块的人的身体各部位上。但现在，他却身处英格兰。他不受控制地抽搐着，喝着白兰地，谈论着新教教义，而且这一切都是和一个来自我老家——威尔特郡索尔兹伯里的人进行的。来自索尔兹伯里地区？
Yes. I mean, it's great to have Wiltshire in the Salisbury area on the show. Dominic, I'll be honest, my worry when you suggested doing Peter the Great was that Salisbury wouldn't get a look in, but how wrong I was. The weirdest thing is not just that he's chatting about Christian doctrine with people from the Salisbury area, it's the fact that he's doing it under a false name. So he's traveled incognito. I mean, this is such a mad story. The Tsar of all the rushes has basically taken an extended gap year to travel anonymously to Western Europe and to hang around in shipyards and in taverns interfering with actresses and kind of
是的。我是说，能在节目里请到威尔特郡索尔兹伯里地区的人真是太棒了。多米尼克，老实说，当你建议做彼得大帝这个主题时，我的担心是索尔兹伯里不会在节目里露面，但我错得多么离谱啊。最诡异的不仅是他和索尔兹伯里地区的人大谈基督教教义，而是他竟然是用假名在做这件事。也就是说他是隐姓埋名出行的。我的意思是，这故事简直太疯狂了。全俄罗斯沙皇基本上是请了一个超长间隔年，匿名去西欧旅游，在造船厂和小酒馆里闲逛，干扰女演员，然后
behaving in ludicrous ways. Wheelbarrow races. We both love a wheelbarrow race. We've only told that story 20 times on the rest of history. And now we're going to tell us again. Brilliant. So should we get back to where we left off? So the summer of 1689, Peter has deposed Sophia. He's 17 years old. He is now, we haven't actually described him physically.
做出各种荒谬的行为。独轮车比赛。我们俩都很喜欢独轮车比赛。我们在《历史的余烬》里已经讲过这个故事20遍了。现在我们要再讲一遍。太棒了。那么，我们应该回到我们上次中断的地方吗？1689年夏天，彼得废黜了索菲亚。他当时17岁。他现在——我们其实还没在生理上描述过他。
He is a massive bloke. He's six foot seven. He's very kind of angular. He's a massive bloke. He's six foot seven. He's very kind of angular. He's got long brown hair and he's got a mustache. Interesting not a beard. Yeah, not a beard. Now Bishop Burnett mentioned his convulsive motions. So some people say, well, maybe he's just very restless.
他是个大块头。身高六英尺七英寸。身材非常硬朗。他是个大块头。身高六英尺七英寸。身材非常硬朗。他留着长长的棕色头发，还留着胡子。有趣的是，他没有留胡须。是的，没有胡须。刚才伯内特主教提到了他的抽搐动作。所以有些人说，也许他只是太坐立不安了。
He's very impatient and stuff. But other people say maybe he's got a kind of a nervous tick because don't forget when he was 10 years old, he saw his family chopped up and stamped on that would give you bad mental health, wouldn't it? I think better help or any mental health provider would have had a field day with pizza. The great to be completely honest with you. But I think it's also possible he's mildly epileptic. There are lots of descriptions of him when he's in Europe having sort of fits on the
他很不耐烦之类的。但也有人说，也许他有某种神经抽搐，因为别忘了，当他10岁的时候，他亲眼目睹了家人们被砍碎和践踏，这会毁了你的心理健康，对吧？说句实话，如果当时有BetterHelp或任何心理健康服务机构，面对彼得大帝绝对能大赚一笔。但我也觉得，他可能还有轻度癫痫。有很多关于他在欧洲时的描述，说他面部
left hand side of his face or his arm, his eyes rolling back in his head, all of this sort of stuff. And I think it's also fair to say Tom, he doesn't have the best and healthiest lifestyle. No, because actually, although he's taken supreme power, he then sort of gives it away because he says to his mother, you know, can you run Russia for me please? Because I just want to hang around with my mates, with my soldiers. And his lathes. And his lathes. And he wants to spend a lot of time.
左侧或手臂在抽搐，双眼上翻等等诸如此类的事情。而且汤姆，我觉得有一点也很公平，那就是他的生活方式其实并不健康。没错，因为实际上，尽管他掌握了最高权力，但他随后却把它放权了，因为他对母亲说，你知道的，你能帮我管理俄罗斯吗？因为我只想和我的同伴们、我的士兵们混在一起。还有他的车床。还有他的车床。他想花大量时间。
He loves the German suburbs, so this place we talked about last time, which is full of kind of Scotsmen and Dutchmen and things. And they're all smoking pipes outside Protestant churches and talking to women, which the Orthodox Church doesn't approve of at all. Which the Orthodox Church doesn't approve of at all. And his closest friends, or some of them at least, come from the German suburb. So we talked last time, we promised we talk about General Gordon. We always liked General Gordon on the show.
他很喜欢德国人聚居区，也就是我们上次谈到的那个地方，那里到处都是苏格兰人、荷兰人什么的。他们都在新教教堂外面抽烟斗，和女人们聊天，正教会对此绝对是无法容忍的。正教会对此绝对是无法容忍的。他最亲密的朋友，或者说其中一部分，都来自德国人聚居区。所以我们上次谈过，我们承诺过要聊聊戈登将军。我们在节目里一向很喜欢戈登将军。
This is a different General Gordon, not the bloke who died in cartoon, but still a friend of the show. Yeah. He's a Scottish mercenary who came from the Highlands. He came from Catholic family. So he basically left Scotland and then he had an amazing career actually. He fought for the Swedes against the Poles, then he fought for the Poles against the Swedes, then he fought for the Swedes against the Poles again, and then he
这是一个不同的戈登将军，不是死在喀土穆的那位，但依然是节目的好朋友。是的。他是一名来自苏格兰高地的雇佣兵。他出身天主教家庭。所以他基本上离开了苏格兰，随后度过了一段传奇的职业生涯。他为瑞典人效力对抗波兰人，然后为波兰人效力对抗瑞典人，接着又为瑞典人效力对抗波兰人，然后又
fought for the Poles against the Swedes again. Oh that's fine isn't it, that's legitimate. Yeah. I mean nobody really minds about that. That's how 17th century warfare works. It's basically like being a star footballer. You transfer from team to team. I think you can't fight against your own country, but you can fight for others. And that's completely legitimate. And he ended up serving the czars. And this guy, General Gordon becomes basically Peter's chief military advisor,
为波兰人效力对抗瑞典人。哦，这很正常对吧，这是合法的。是的。我的意思是没人真正在意这个。17th世纪的战争就是这样运作的。这基本上就像当一个明星足球运动员。你从一支球队转会到另一支球队。我想你不能和自己的国家作战，但你可以为其他人作战。这完全是合法的。他最后开始为沙皇效力。而这家伙，戈登将军，基本上成了彼得的首席军事顾问，
his tutor, I suppose. And then there's another mercenary who is called France Lafour, who's from Geneva, who basically is a massive drinker and a dancer, charming. His house, we're told, is always full of women. Peter's biographer Robert K. Massey describes as, Roller King bucks some sturdy wenches who did not take offense at barracks language or the admiring touch of rough male hands. So that kind of gives you a sense of the general vibe at these occasions.
我想可以说是他的导师。然后还有另一个雇佣兵叫弗朗茨·勒福尔（Franz Lefort），来自日内瓦，他基本上是个狂饮者和舞蹈家，很有魅力。我们听说他的房子里总是挤满了女人。彼得的传记作家罗伯特·K·马西（Robert K. Massey）将其描述为：“罗克·金巴克斯（Roller King bucks）和一些强壮的姑娘，她们对军营里的粗俗语言或粗糙男性之手的爱抚并不感到冒犯。”所以这大概让你对这些场合的总体氛围有所体会。
I think it's fair to say. Yes. And just on the topic of rough male hands, Peter's hands are very calloused, aren't they? Because he's been with his lathes and all of that. Right. Because it's been like chopping stones or whatever he's doing. Yeah. And so when he goes on his gap year and he meets with all these, you know, members
我觉得这么说挺公正的。是的，就粗糙的男性之手这个话题而言，彼得的手上有很多老茧，对吧？因为他一直在用他的车床和其他工具。没错。因为这就像是在凿石头或者他正在干的什么活。是的。所以当他去过间隔年并遇到所有这些，你知道的，
of royalty and stuff, he's always showing off his calluses. He is, he's very proud of them. In an age when people would be proud of not having calloused hands, he's quite the reverse. So over time, Peter and this bloke Le Four and their pal, so actually he picks up Le Four's girlfriend who's called Anna Mons and she loves a drink and a lot of she becomes his mistress. Anyway peter and all these pals they basically they form something that they call the jolly company. I feel i don't actually think either of us would really enjoy life in the jolly company i'd have hated it i think you might enjoy it for a day. It's basically a stag do, a massive stag do. I hate stag dos. There's often about 80 of them, sometimes as many as 200. Remember, Peter is the Tsar of Russia and he's 17 years old. They will roam the land,
皇室成员之类的人时，他总是显摆自己的老茧。他确实如此，他为此感到非常自豪。在一个人们会为没有老茧而感到骄傲的时代，他却恰恰相反。随着时间的推移，彼得和这个叫勒福尔的家伙以及他们的伙伴们——实际上他接手了勒福尔的女朋友，名叫安娜·蒙斯（Anna Mons），她非常喜欢喝酒，后来成了他的情妇。总之，彼得和所有这些伙伴们，他们基本上组建了一个他们称之为“快乐公司”（the jolly company）的组织。我觉得，其实我们俩谁都不会真正喜欢“快乐公司”里的生活，我会恨死它的，你可能还会享受一天吧。这基本上就是一个单身派对，一个规模巨大的单身派对。我讨厌单身派对。他们通常有大约80人，有时甚至多达200人。记住，彼得是俄罗斯沙皇，而且他才17岁。他们会在各地游荡，
basically turning up at Russian nobleman's houses and saying, you know, put us up. And they'll have these enormous feasts. The feast normally starts at midday. It's actually very much like our working lunches at The Rest Is History with the production team. Yeah, it is. The feast starts at midday and it lasts till the next day. They have a pause every now and again to have a smoke
基本上就是出现在俄罗斯贵族的宅邸里，然后说，你知道的，接待我们一下吧。然后他们就会举行这种规模巨大的盛宴。盛宴通常在中午开始。这其实非常像我们在《历史的余烬》节目中和制作团队的工作午餐。是的，确实如此。盛宴从中午开始，一直持续到第二天。他们每隔一段时间就会停下来抽根烟，
or to play bowls or to shoot muskets or let off fireworks. And isn't this kind of shenanigans with bears and bellows and things? Right, exactly. So there's a lot of beer drinking. It's very like the rest is history working lunches. There's a lot of beer drinking and toasts, but there's also pranks. We love a prank. So if there's a fat man there, they'll often strip the fat man and drag him across ice on his bear bottom. They would shove candles into you, insert candles and light them. At least one man is killed by having air blown up him with bellows. So they insert bellows into him and blow you up.
或者玩地掷球，或者发射滑膛枪或放烟花。还有跟熊、风箱之类的恶作剧对吧？没错，正是如此。所以有很多啤酒狂欢。这真的很像《历史的余烬》的工作午餐。有很多啤酒狂欢和干杯，但也有恶作剧。我们喜欢恶作剧。所以如果那里有个胖子，他们经常会把这个胖子扒光，然后拖着他的光屁股在冰面上滑行。他们会把蜡烛塞进你的身体，塞进蜡烛并点燃。至少有一个人是被用风箱往体内吹气给弄死的。所以他们把风箱塞进他体内，然后把你吹胀。
That's what I remember. The bellows jape. Would you burst? Do you think he burst? I mean, I don't know. Because if they're playing jakes on fat people, presumably if you blow a fat person up with the bellows, there's more capacity. Yeah. I mean, Dominic, I've mentioned it before, but the brilliant evocation of all this, the japs and the pranks. Yeah. And the frankly kind of murderous jollity of the jolly company is brilliantly evoked in The Great. Right. The Catherine the Great series. With Nicholas Holt, who is playing Peter the Great's grandson, but I think he's actually playing Peter the Great in this. Loads of toasts and going huzzah all the time. Yeah, this is what's happening now
我记得就是这样。风箱恶作剧。你觉得他会爆吗？你会觉得他爆了吗？我的意思是，我不知道。因为如果他们对胖子开玩笑，假设你用风箱把一个胖子吹胀，那容积应该更大。是的，多米尼克，我以前提过，但对这一切的精彩唤起，那些恶作剧。是的。还有“快乐公司”那种坦率说带有杀戮性质的狂欢，在电视剧《凯瑟琳大帝》（The Great）中得到了精彩的展现。没错。叶卡捷琳娜大帝的系列剧。尼古拉斯·霍尔特（Nicholas Holt）在剧中饰演彼得大帝的孙子，但我认为他其实是在扮演彼得大帝本人。有大量的祝酒，嘴里一直喊着“乌拉（huzzah）”。是的，现在正在发生的就是这个。
There is a slight you could say there's a slight political side to this Because we talked last time about how Peter loves to kind of do this role-playing and quite subversive role-playing He loves giving people like fake titles and nicknames and stuff So the jolly company have their own sort of what's called a mock czar, a guy who he calls the Prince Caesar. Who's a friend of his called Fedor Romanovsky. And Peter calls him your majesty. When Peter writes a letter to him, he always sent signs himself.
这里有一个轻微的——你可以说这有一点点政治色彩，因为我们上期节目谈过，彼得非常喜欢这种角色扮演，而且是非常颠覆性的角色扮演。他喜欢给人们起假头衔和绰号之类的。所以“快乐公司”有他们自己的某种所谓的“假沙皇”，一个被他称为“凯撒亲王”的家伙。这是他的一个朋友，名叫费多尔·罗曼诺夫斯基（Fedor Romanovsky）。彼得叫他“陛下”。当彼得写信给他时，他总是署名：
You know, I'm your slave. I'm your bondsman and stuff. And this guy, Romanovsky has to preside over the meetings, the jolly company. He almost pretends to be the czar, but he loves a prank. So his great prank, you would love this time if you've turned up when you arrive, especially if you were kind of a newbie, you have to drink a large peppered brandy that is offered to you by a trained bear. And if you say, oh, it's not for me. I don't like.
你知道的，我是你的奴隶。我是你的农奴之类的话。而这家伙，罗曼诺夫斯基必须主持“快乐公司”的会议。他几乎是在假装自己是沙皇，但他非常喜欢恶作剧。所以他的伟大恶作剧——如果你在抵达时刚好赶上，特别是如果你是个新人的话，你一定会喜欢这个——你必须喝下一大杯加了胡椒的白兰地，这杯酒是由一头受过训练的熊端给你的。如果你说，哦，这不适合我。我不喜欢。
I don't like trained bears either. While we're at it, the bear has been trained not just to offer you cups of brandy, but to strip you naked. Imagine being stripped by a bear. That's not the kind of thing that Voitech got up to. I'm glad to say. No, no. our previous bear. We don't know the name of this bear, but it sounds absolutely splendid. So as time goes on, this becomes more and more formalized and ritualized.
我也同样不喜欢受过训练的熊。顺便说一句，这头熊受过的训练不仅是给你端几杯白兰地，还要把你剥光。想象一下被一头熊剥光衣服的感觉。值得庆幸的是，这可不是沃伊泰克（Voitech）会干的事。我很高兴不是。不，不。我们以前的那头熊。我们不知道这头熊叫什么名字，但它听起来绝对棒极了。随着时间推移，这一切变得越来越规范化和仪式化。
So by the 1690s, the Jolly Company has been organized into what Peter calls the, the all joking, all drunken synod of fools and jesters. This clearly does have a slight political edge because it's a parody of the, of the church. So they have cardinals, they have bishops, they have deacons. Peter is just a deacon. But Dominic, the fact that there are cardinals, which you don't get in the Orthodox church, but you do get in the Catholic church. I mean, he can say this is a parody of the heretical Caesarist Catholic church, can't he? Yeah, he can. I think what lies behind this.
所以在1690年代，“快乐公司”被组织成了彼得所称的“全滑稽、全醉酒的愚人和小丑宗教会议”（the all joking, all drunken synod of fools and jesters）。这显然带有一点点政治色彩，因为它是对教会的一种讽刺。所以他们有红衣主教、有主教、有执事。彼得自己只是个执事。但多米尼克，这里有红衣主教——正教会里是没有红衣主教的，但在天主教里是有的。我的意思是，他可以说是对异端凯撒主义天主教教会的一种讽刺，对吧？是的，他可以。我认为这背后的核心是。
So actually he started doing this, the all drunken synod after there was the accession of a new patriarch who was very anti-Western, very traditionalist. He was called Adrian and Peter despised Adrian. And I think he clearly wanted the all drunken synod to mock the Orthodox church, but he knew he couldn't do it directly. So the, the rituals are Catholic exactly as you say, because it would be far too subversive. Yeah. Just on Peter's attitude to the Orthodox Church, I mean, he is still a devout believer, isn't
事实上，他开始搞这个“全醉酒宗教会议”是在新任大牧首上任之后，这个大牧首非常反西方、非常传统主义。他叫阿德里安（Adrian），彼得非常鄙视阿德里安。我认为他显然是想通过“全醉酒宗教会议”来嘲弄正教会，但他知道自己不能直接这么做。所以，这些仪式完全是天主教的，正如你所说，因为那样做会太具颠覆性了。是的。就彼得对正教会的态度而言，我的意思是，他仍然是一个虔诚的信徒，对吧？
he? Yes, he is. It's not like he is a kind of Frederick the Great or someone like that who is contemptuous of Christianity. No, he's not at all. He's very, he's still pious, but he's fascinated by other forms of Christianity as we'll see when he goes abroad, he wants to find out all about them. He's curious.
是的，他是。他可不是那种对基督教充满蔑不屑的腓特烈大帝（Frederick the Great）或类似的人。不，他一点也不是。他依然很虔诚，但他对其他形式的基督教着迷，正如我们随后看到他出国时，他想要了解关于它们的一切。他充满了好奇心。
Yeah. So that's why he's talking to Gilbert Burnett. I think it's fair to say he's a very violent man. He's very impatient, but he's not intolerant of other ideas. He's interested in other ideas, I think, which makes them different from a lot of Russian Tsars, but you still wouldn't want to see him coming towards you with a pair of bellows. A pair of bellows and a bear. That's terrifying.
是的，这就是为什么他在和吉尔伯特·伯内特交谈。我觉得可以公平地说，他是一个非常暴力的人。他非常不耐烦，但他对其他观点并不狭隘。他对其他观点很感兴趣，我觉得这让他区别于许多俄罗斯沙皇，但你依然不会想看到他手里拿着风箱朝你走来。手里拿着风箱和一头熊。那太可怕了。
No. So he has a mock prince pope, who's his old tutor, who's a man called Nikita Zotov, who presides over this synod. So on feast days, on religious feast days, to mock the church, they have their biggest kind of antics and rituals. And the Pope wears gloves made of my skins. It's bonkers. So on Christmas they ride around on slays, a sleigh drawn by 12 bald men.
没错。所以他有一个虚构的“亲王教皇”，就是他的老导师，一个叫尼基塔·佐托夫（Nikita Zotov）的人，他来主持这个宗教会议。因此在节日里，在宗教节日里，为了嘲弄教会，他们会举行最大规模的滑稽动作和仪式。教皇穿着老鼠皮做的手套。这太疯狂了。所以在圣诞节，他们会乘雪橇四处游行，雪橇由12个光头男人拉着。
The mock Pope is wearing a tin hat and a costume made of playing cards, which seems bonkers and the others are all wearing their clothes inside out as you said gloves of mice skins. Oh I thought it was the paper war then so everyone's wearing it that's a lot of mice you've had to be killed. Oh yeah and their sleighs are pulled by pigs and bears. Such a lot of bears. I can't believe you could train a bear to pull it.
这位假教皇戴着一顶锡帽，穿着一套用扑克牌制作的戏服，这看起来太疯狂了，其他人也都把衣服反穿，正如你所说的，戴着老鼠皮手套。哦，我当时以为那是纸牌大战呢，所以每个人都穿着——那得杀死多少只老鼠啊。哦，是的，他们的雪橇是由猪和熊拉的。有这么多的熊。我真不敢相信你能训练一头熊来拉雪橇。
Well maybe you could. It's really not the same bear who's stripping people naked. Well I think if you can train a bear to strip you bare. If you don't want to, yeah. A mug of spice whiskey, whatever it was. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
嗯，也许你可以吧。这真的跟那个把人剥光的熊不是同一头。嗯，我觉得如果你能训练一头熊把你剥光的话。如果你不想的话，对吧。一杯香料威士忌，不管那是什么。是的。是的。是的。
Yeah. Anyway. So is Peter doing anything other than sort of blowing people up with bellows and things? Yes. He's doing loads of naval stuff. So he goes up to Archangel. You mentioned Archangel in the previous episode. It's on the white sea.
好吧。那么，彼得除了用风箱把人吹胀之类的恶作剧之外，还在做别的吗？是的。他在搞大量的海军事务。所以他去了阿尔汉格尔斯克（Archangel）。你在上一集里提到过阿尔汉格尔斯克。它位于白海。
It's the only Russian outlet to the sea. It's, it's a little bit of a forerunner of St. Petersburg actually, because it has English and Dutch sailors who live there, it has sort of churches, Protestant churches. When you go to Archangel, there's taverns full of Dutch sea captains smoking pipes and talking about William of Orange, and he loves that and he goes up there and it's actually at this point that he designs a flag for his sort of Navy because he's very interested in Holland. He models it on the flag of the Dutch States General but he reorders the colors. So it's the white, blue and red flag of today's Russian Federation.
那是俄罗斯唯一通往海洋的出海口。它其实有点像是圣彼得堡的先驱，因为那里住着英国和荷兰水手，还有各种新教教堂。当你去到阿尔汉格尔斯克，那里到处都是抽着烟斗、谈论奥兰治的威廉（William of Orange）的荷兰船长的小酒馆，他非常喜欢这种氛围，于是他去了那里。正是在这个时候，他为他的某种海军设计了一面旗帜，因为他对荷兰非常感兴趣。他以荷兰国会（States General）的旗帜为蓝本，但重新排列了颜色。所以这就是今天俄罗斯联邦的白、蓝、红三色旗。
So it's basically Dutch. It's Dutch, exactly. So the Russian Navy's basically Dutch. It's Dutch. Exactly. So the Russian Navy is English and the flag is Dutch. Yeah. Putin keeps quiet about that, doesn't he? Yeah, he doesn't play that up as much as he could. So his first war, as he thinks, I'll have a little crack at the Ottomans because they'd still got this deal with the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth and code.
所以它基本上就是荷兰的。它就是荷兰的，完全没错。所以俄罗斯海军基本上是荷兰的。它是荷兰的。完全没错。所以俄罗斯海军是英国的，而旗帜是荷兰的。是的，普京对这一点一直保持低调，对吧？是的，他没有像本来可以的那样大肆宣扬这一点。所以他的第一场战争，他想，“我要去试着打击一下奥斯曼人”，因为他们和波兰立陶宛联邦之间还有这个协议。
They're meant to be fighting the Ottomans. So he decides he wants to capture Azov on the Black Sea. The first go at it in 1695 doesn't work, but in 1696 he goes down the River Don with loads of Cossacks and he captures Azov from the Ottomans. And this is the first Russian victory for 20 years. So it's a great moment. And he has his outlet now. It's not quite on the black sea. It's something on a sea of Azov. So he needs to go a little bit further to get into the black sea. However, it's a start.
他们本应该与奥斯曼人作战。所以他决定夺取黑海边的亚速（Azov）。1695年的第一次尝试没有成功，但在1696年，他带着大批哥萨克顺着顿河而下，从奥斯曼人手中夺取了亚速。这是俄罗斯20年来取得的第一场胜利。所以这是一个伟大的时刻。他现在有了自己的出海口。虽然不在真正的黑海边。而是在亚速海。所以他还需要再往前走一点才能进入黑海。不过，这总算是一个开始。
He has a triumph in Moscow. And here again, you see his kind of Westernizing ambitions because previously when Russian czars had triumphs, they were very orthodox occasions. There's lots of sort of chanting and waving around of icons. So very second Rome. Exactly. But, um, Peter's is really very first Rome. He has statues of Hercules and of Mars.
他在莫斯科举行了一场凯旋游行。在这里，你再次看到了他那西化的雄心壮志，因为在此之前，当俄罗斯沙皇凯旋时，通常都是非常正统的东正教仪式。有大量的吟唱和圣像挥舞。非常具有“第二罗马”的色彩。完全正确。但是，彼得的游行非常有“第一罗马”的风格。他有大力神赫拉克勒斯和战神玛尔斯的雕像。
They put Julius Caesar's I came, I saw I conquered Veney, Vidi, Viki, on a, on kind of classical gates. As always Peter, his role playing, his performative humility is on display. So he gets this bloke who was the Prince Pope who presumably is not now dressed in playing cards with kind of my skin gloves to lead the procession. And he walks with the captains of his galleys wearing an ordinary German captain's uniform. And he'd performed very bravely, hadn't he?
他们在古典风格的城门上挂着尤利乌斯·恺撒的“我来、我见、我征服”（Veni, Vidi, Vici）。一如既往地，彼得的角色扮演、他表演式的谦逊展露无遗。所以他让那个扮演“亲王教皇”的家伙——这个人现在大概没有穿着扑克牌服装戴着老鼠皮手套了——来引领游行队伍。他穿着普通的德国船长制服，和他的桨帆船船长们一起步行。他表现得非常勇敢，对吧？
In the campaign against Azov as an artillery man. He had, he'd done well. He'd done very well. And then just weeks after this victory comes an unbelievable announcement from the foreign ministry. Peter is sending a great embassy to Europe, to England, to Denmark, to the Dutch States, to Brandenburg, to Venice. This embassy is going to be led by his mate, Franz LeFour, and they're
在攻打亚速的战役中，作为一名炮兵。他确实表现得很出色。他表现得非常出色。就在这场胜利几周后，外交部发布了一个令人难以置信的公告。彼得要派遣一个宏大的使团前往欧洲，前往英格兰、丹麦、荷兰各省、勃兰登堡、威尼斯。这个使团将由他的好友弗朗茨·勒福尔率领，他们将去
going to recruit officers and ship rights and sailors to come back to Russia and to build a fleet, and they're going to learn from the advanced nations of the West. This is an extraordinary thing for a Tsar to do, to send some of his closest mates. But then, a rumor goes around Moscow, Peter's actually going to go with them. And he's not going to go with them as the Tsar, He's going to go as a member of the diplomatic staff in disguise. So this is his business about pretending he's not the Tsar which he loves to do. Even though he's by miles the tallest member of the embassy. He's the tallest person.
招募军官、造船工和水手回到俄罗斯来建造一支舰队，他们要向西方的先进国家学习。对于沙皇来说，派他最亲密的几个密友去做这种事是一件非同寻常的事。但是随后，莫斯科流传起一个传言：彼得实际上要和他们一起去。而且他不是以沙皇的身份去，他将伪装成外交随员的一员随行。所以这就是他那种假装自己不是沙皇的把戏，他太喜欢这样了。尽管他是使团里身材最高大的人，高出好几倍。他是最高的人。
So there are multiple reasons why he wants to do this because this is an extraordinary thing. No Russian Tsar has ever traveled outside Russia except when they're fighting before. It's unprecedented. Now one reason is he wants to get allies to strengthen the alliance against the Ottomans because he's very keen on this Black Sea kind of breakthrough. But the more obvious kind of personal reason is that he is just absolutely fascinated with the West with Holland and England in particular. He wants to to the dockyards he wants to study that ship building techniques. I need clearly knows i think so many Russians know that the gap between Russian the West has never been greater than in the West this is the age of newton of Leibniz of the financial and scientific revolutions of stock exchanges and newspapers and things.
所以他想这么做有多种原因，因为这是一件非同寻常的事。在此之前，没有任何俄罗斯沙皇在非战争时期去过俄罗斯境外。这是史无前例的。现在，其中一个原因是他想争取盟友，以加强针对奥斯曼帝国的同盟，因为他非常热衷于在黑海实现某种突破。但更明显的、带有个人色彩的原因是，他 simplesmente 对西方、尤其是对荷兰和英格兰着迷至极。他想去造船厂，他想研究那里的造船技术。我非常清楚地知道，我想很多俄罗斯人也知道，俄罗斯与西方的差距从来没有像现在这样巨大，在西方，这是一个属于牛顿、莱布尼茨、金融和科学革命、股票交易所和报纸的时代。
And Russia is in danger of falling centuries behind. And he has seal made that has the inscription, I am a student and I'm looking for teachers. Yeah. You know, so he, he's pretty explicit about it. Why would the Dutch or the English or whoever be willing to teach a potential rival about the reasons for their lead? I mean, if you have a technological lead, why would you share it with somebody who is potentially quite a major threat?
而俄罗斯正面临着落后几个世纪的危险。他定制了一枚印章，上面刻着铭文：“我是一名学生，我正在寻找老师。”是的。你知道的，所以他对此非常坦率。为什么荷兰人或英格兰人或其他什么人会愿意把他们保持领先的原因教给一个潜在的竞争对手呢？我的意思是，如果你拥有技术优势，你为什么要把它分享给一个可能构成重大威胁的人呢？
A fairly obvious reason I would have thought is that he's Orthodox and he's not Catholic. So if you're a Protestant power, he could conceivably be an ally against Louis XIV, right? Who is the great figure of the ages, isn't he? Yeah. He doesn't go to France in this trip. He goes to the two great Protestant adversaries of France. I think they're flattered, England and the Dutch Republic, by Peter's attentions. And maybe they're hoping to, well, Gilbert Burnett, I mean, he's clearly trying to win Peter for Anglicanism. For Anglicanism, as we will see, as we will see people in England thought,
我觉得一个相当显而易见的原因是他是正教徒而不是天主教徒。所以如果你是一个新教强权，他完全有可能成为对抗路易十四的盟友，对吧？路易十四是那个时代最伟大的人物，不是吗？是的。他这次旅行没有去法国。他去了法国的两个伟大新教敌对国。我想英格兰和荷兰共和国对彼得的关注感到受宠若惊。也许他们正指望——嗯，吉尔伯特·伯内特，我的意思是，他显然在试图把彼得争取到英国国教这边来。为了英国国教，正如我们将看到的，正如我们将看到的那样，英格兰的人们认为，
this is brilliant. We could basically get an ally in Russia. We could have an Anglican ally. Exactly. I know that sounds bonkers, but is it any more bonkers than the Tsar of Russia going in disguise on a massive gap year to the West? I don't think it is. I suppose not.
这太棒了。我们基本上可以在俄罗斯找到一个盟友，我们可以拥有一个英国国教的盟友。没错。我知道这听起来很疯狂，但比起俄罗斯沙皇隐姓埋名去西方进行超长间隔年，这还要更疯狂吗？我觉得并没有。我想也是吧。
So he decides he's going to set off. His mother, by the way, is dead at this point. And actually his brother Ivan has died as well. So he leaves his mate Romanovsky, the guy who has the bear. So the Prince Caesar, the Prince Caesar, as he's called. He says, you're commanding the troops. You have basically command of law and order while I'm gone. As he leaves, he has a farewell banquet. And he hears that there's been some bitching among the Streltsy about him. They've been saying, oh, he has a farewell banquet and he hears that there's been some bitching among the Streltsy about him. They've been saying, oh, he's going off to the West, you know, he's going to betray us
所以他决定动身。顺便说一句，他的母亲此时已经去世了。事实上，他的哥哥伊万也已经去世了。所以他留下了他的好友罗曼诺夫斯基，也就是那个带着熊的家伙。也就是“亲王亲王（Prince Caesar）”，“亲王恺撒”，正如他被称为的那样。他对他说：“你负责指挥军队。在我离开期间，你基本上拥有法律与秩序的指挥权。”在他离开时，他举行了一场告别宴会。他听说斯特列利茨军里有些人一直在抱怨他。他们一直在说，哦，他举行了一场告别宴会，并且听说斯特列利茨军内部有些关于他的怨言。他们一直在说，哦，他这是要去西方了，
all to foreigners. And he has this Streltsy colonel and two noblemen executed. He has their limbs cut off with an axe and then they're beheaded. And then he gets the coffin of Sofia's uncle. So one of the Miller Slavsky family, he gets this coffin dragged by pigs into red square pigs. There's obviously a whole kind of stables full of pigs who are trained to drag things. Right.
你知道的，他要把我们所有人都出卖给外国人。于是他下令处决了一名斯特列利茨军上校和两名贵族。他用斧头砍断了他们的四肢，然后将他们斩首。接着，他让人把索菲亚的叔叔——米洛斯拉夫斯基家族的一员——的棺材用猪拖到红场上。猪。这显然是一整圈训练有素、专门用来拖东西的猪圈。没错。
And the coffin is opened beneath the chopping block where these guys have been executed so that their blood will spatter the face of Sophia's dead uncle. I mean, this is by no means the most sadistic thing that Peter will do. He loves a really, really horrendous kind of sadistic jape. And there are a lot of them to come. So after he's done this, he sets off. He's traveling as Peter Mikhailov.
棺材被打开，就放在这些被处决之人的行刑木桩下方，这样他们的血就会溅到索菲亚死去的叔叔的脸上。我的意思是，这绝不是彼得做过的最虐待狂的事情。他非常喜欢真正极其可怕的虐待狂恶作剧。而且接下来还会有很多这样的事。做完这一切后，他动身了。他化名为彼得·米哈伊洛夫（Peter Mikhailov）。
There's 250 people, loads of noblemen, musicians, coachmen, priests, secretaries, four dwarfs, of course, of course he's Peter Mikhailov. If you tell anybody who he is, he will kill you, but he all, he wants people to kind of recognize him and be polite to him at the same time. So he's using the incognito thing basically as a way to get out of formalities. Yeah. All the boring stuff, but he still wants to see fireworks displays in his honor and for people to present him with enormous goblets of wine.
随行有250人，包括大批贵族、音乐家、车夫、牧师、秘书、四个侏儒——当然少不了侏儒。他就是彼得·米哈伊洛夫。如果你告诉任何人他的真实身份，他就会杀了你，但他同时又希望人们能认出他并对保持礼貌。所以他基本上是把隐身当作一种摆脱繁文缛节的方式。是的。所有无聊的繁文缛节，但他仍然希望看到为他举办的烟花表演，希望人们向他敬献巨大的美酒高脚杯。
He's a cakeist. Yeah. He's a total cakeist. He wants to have his cake and eat it. So they set off, they cross the frontier into what's then called Livonia, which is kind of Estonia, Latvia, which is part of the Swedish Empire and they arrive in Riga Peter does not like Riga at all and he hates the Swedes because the Swedes take the incognito thing very seriously And they say they don't have a banquet for him
他是个“全都要”主义者。是的。他是彻头彻尾的“全都要”主义者。他想鱼与熊掌兼得。于是他们动身了，穿过边境进入当时被称为利沃尼亚（Livonia）的地区，也就是现在的爱沙尼亚和拉脱维亚一带，这里当时是瑞典帝国的一部分，他们抵达了里加。彼得一点也不喜欢里加，他痛恨瑞典人，因为瑞典人把隐姓埋名这事看得非常严肃，他们拒绝为他举办宴会。
You know their Swedes respond exactly as you would expect the Swedes to very sober very sober They so well if you're if you're not Peter the great great no fireworks The Swedes respond exactly as you would expect the Swedes to. Very sober. Very sober. They say, well, if you're not Peter the Great, great. No fireworks. By the way, you have to pay for your own board and lodging. This he's really offended by. The Swedish lack of hospitality. He's shocked at this.
你知道的，瑞典人的反应完全符合你对瑞典人的预期：非常严肃，非常严肃。他们说，好吧，如果你不是彼得大帝，那就太好了。没有烟花。瑞典人的反应完全符合你对瑞典人的预期。非常严肃。非常严肃。他们说，好吧，如果你不是彼得大帝，那就太好了。没有烟花。顺便说一句，你得自己付食宿费。这让他感到非常被冒犯。瑞典人缺乏好客之道。这让他感到震惊。
But also he's fascinated by kind of fortifications and things. So he goes off to inspect the defenses of Riga. But because he's incognito, a Swedish sentry spots him and threatens to shoot him. Yeah, but also Dominic I mean even if they did This is a fortress next to a potential enemy and then the leader of that enemy is Sketching. Yeah, your fortress. Exactly. I mean the Russians they don't tend to like, you know Foreigners turning up and making sketches of their nuclear refineries or they're right
但同时他又对各种防御工事非常着迷。所以他跑去视察里加的防御设施。但因为他隐瞒了身份，一个瑞典哨兵认出了他并威胁要开枪射击他。是的，但多米尼克，我的意思是，即使他们没认出来，这也是一个紧邻潜在敌人的堡垒，而那个敌人的最高领袖却在画草图。是的，在画你们的堡垒。完全没错。我的意思是，俄罗斯人通常也不喜欢，你知道的，
Exactly if I had a mere Putin turned up at a British submarine base in disguise, clearly, obviously Vladimir Putin, and then was offended when people challenged him. Yeah, but he hated this. He hated Riga. And 13 years later, when his army was attacking Riga, he insisted on firing the first shells into the city. I do like a man who bears a grudge. He said, I thank God for allowing me to see the beginning of our revenge on this accursed
外国人跑来给他们的核精炼厂画草图，或者他们正确的做法是。完全没错。如果普京本人隐瞒身份出现在英国潜水艇基地，显然就是弗拉基米尔·普京本人，然后当人们盘问他时他还觉得被冒犯了。是的，但他对此恨之入骨。他恨里加。13年后，当他的军队进攻里加时，他坚持要亲手向这座城市发射第一枚炮弹。我真的很喜欢一个记仇的男人。他说：“我感谢上帝让我看到了我们对这个受诅咒的地方开始复仇的时刻。”
place. I mean, you really wouldn't want him as an enemy, would you? You wouldn't want him as a friend either, frankly, if he comes at you with some bellows. He goes into a place called Courland, which is now kind of Lithuania. He goes through Königsberg, now Kaliningrad. He meets the elector of Brandenburg, who is the future Frederick the First of Prussia. They have a great time. They go hunting.
我的意思是，你真的不会想跟他作对，对吧？说实话，如果你带着风箱去找他，你也不会想跟他做朋友。他去了一个叫做库尔兰（Courland）的地方，也就是现在的立陶宛一带。他穿过哥尼斯堡，即现在的加里宁格勒。他会见了勃兰登堡选帝侯，也就是未来的普鲁士国王腓特烈一世。他们玩得很开心。他们去打猎。
They have the fireworks display. They watch bears fighting. They stage a bear fight. Do you know, I mean, I had no idea that bear action played such a part in royal embassies and entertainment in the 18th century. When we get onto Augustus the strong, all kinds of activities with animals there. Well, foxes. So he meets Sophia of Hanover, who is the mother of George the first.
他们观看了烟花表演。他们观看熊打架，甚至还导演了一场熊斗。你知道吗，我完全不知道熊的活动在18世纪的皇家使团和娱乐活动中竟然占据了如此重要的地位。当我们讲到强力王奥古斯都（Augustus the Strong）时，那里有各种各样的动物活动。嗯，还有狐狸。所以他见到了汉诺威的索菲亚（Sophia of Hanover），她就是乔治一世的母亲。
So she's going to be Queen Anne's heir to maintain the Protestant succession. Exactly. And this is a very funny scene because he'd never met aristocratic Western women before and he's shown in to see them. He's very embarrassed. He doesn't know what to say. He literally covered his face with his hands in embarrassment and he sort of muttered from behind his hands. I don't know what to say. He literally covered his face with his hands and embarrassment and he sort of muttered from behind his hands
所以她将成为安妮女王的继承人，以维持新教王位的继承。没错。这是一个非常有趣的场面，因为他以前从未见过西方的贵族女性，当他被带去见她们时，他感到非常尴尬。他不知道该说些什么。他 literalmente（字面意思）用双手捂住脸掩饰尴尬，然后隔着双手嘟囔着。我不知道该说什么。他 literalmente 用双手捂住脸掩饰尴尬，然后隔着双手嘟囔着：
I don't know what to say and Sophia and her daughter are very nice to him. They say oh, come on. It's fine They have some music they bring in some Hanoverian children including the future George the second and he loves George the second He hugs him and kisses him and puts him on his lap and stuff I mean George second is 14 he doesn't want to be kissed and hugged by a massive great Blake with a hairy mustache and also he dances, doesn't he? With German women and is startled to discover that they're wearing these strange contraptions called corsets because no Russian woman wears a corset.
“我不知道该说什么。”索菲亚和她的女儿对他都很好。她们说，哦，得了吧。没事的。她们放了些音乐，带进来几个汉诺威的小孩，其中包括未来的乔治二世，他非常喜欢乔治二世，拥抱他、亲吻他，把他抱在膝盖上。我的意思是，乔治二世当时14岁，他可不想被一个留着毛茸茸胡子的大块头又亲又抱的。而且他还跳舞，对吧？跟德国女人跳舞，并且惊讶地发现她们穿着一种叫紧身胸衣的奇怪玩意儿，因为没有俄罗斯女人会穿紧身胸衣。
No. So he's very taken with that. He cries out. These German women have devilish hard bones. And there's all much laughing. There's a lot of laughing and actually they are quite fond of him. They were worried that he would get very drunk and he always restrains himself in the presence of aristocratic women.
没有。所以他对这一点大为惊叹。他大声喊道：“这些德国女人有着魔鬼般坚硬的骨头。”现场发出一阵大笑。大家笑得很开心，其实她们还挺喜欢他的。她们原本担心他会喝得大醉，而他在贵族女性面前总是克制自己。
But then the people that he's traveling with, so all his mates and hangers on all the lads, Jolly Company, they get massively drunk and they make up for it. And this is definitely a theme of the trip. So eventually he gets to Holland and he is so excited about this. It's actually quite sweet. He goes on ahead of the rest of his party because he just can't wait. And his destination is a place called Zandam, which is a great kind of shipyard. And they claim in this place that the best shipyard in Holland, There are 50 different companies and they make more than 300 ships a year.
但随后和他同行的人，也就是他所有的密友和随从、那些小伙子们、“快乐公司”的成员们，却喝得酩酊大醉，把这部分的份都补回来了。这绝对是此次行程的一个主题。最终他来到了荷兰，他对此兴奋得无以复加。其实这挺可爱的。他比他的随行人员提前出发，因为他实在等不及了。他的目的地是一个叫赞丹（Zandam）的地方，那是一个伟大的造船厂所在地。当地人声称那是荷兰最好的造船厂，那里有50家不同的公司，每年建造300多艘船。
So this is like for Peter, this is Disneyland ship heaven. It is, it absolutely is. So he arrives on a Sunday and immediately he bumps into a bloke who'd once worked for him in Moscow, a blacksmith called Gerrit Kist and Peter hugs him, kisses him and stuff and kisses, come called Garrett kissed and Peter hugs him. That kisses him and stuff. And kiss says, come and stay in the house next door. I mean, kissed is just can't believe it.
所以对彼得来说，这简直就是迪士尼造船天堂。确实如此，绝对是的。所以他在一个星期天抵达，随即就撞见了一个曾经在莫斯科为他工作过的铁匠，一个叫加里特·基斯特（Gerrit Kist）的铁匠。彼得走过去拥抱他、亲吻他之类的一一拥抱了一个叫加里特·基斯特的人，彼得拥抱了他。亲吻了他之类的。基斯特说：“来我隔壁的房子住吧。”我的意思是，基斯特简直不敢相信。
It's just mind boggling to him that the czar of Russia has turned up in his town and says, I'll move in next door to you, which is what happens. And the next day is a Monday morning. Peter gets up. He's obviously got some money. He goes off and he buys a load of tools. And then he goes to a shipyard run by a man called lynched Roger. And he signs up to work in the shipyard under the name Peter Mikhailov. I mean, can you imagine Donald Trump doing
俄罗斯沙皇竟然出现在他的小镇上，还说“我要搬到你隔壁住”，这简直让他匪夷所思，而这正是发生的事情。第二天是星期一早晨。彼得起床了。他显然带了些钱，出门买了一大堆工具。然后他去了一家由一个叫林奇·罗杰（Lynched Roger）的人经营的造船厂。他以彼得·米哈伊洛夫（Peter Mikhailov）的名字报名在造船厂工作。我的意思是，你能想象唐纳德·特朗普做这种事吗？
this? You know, signing up to work in a call center? No. Well, he did. He worked in McDonald's, didn't he? He did work. So yeah, for like an hour or something. But the thing is, of course, Peter is very conspicuous because he's so tall. And also he's got a very strong Russian accent. So crowds gather to watch him, you know, as he's walking to the shipyard. And this happens within days and he gets very upset.
你知道的，报名去呼叫中心工作？不。嗯，他确实做过，他在麦当劳工作过，对吧？他确实干过。所以，是的，就干了一个小时左右。但问题是，当然，彼得非常显眼，因为他太高了。而且他还有很重的俄罗斯口音。所以当他走向造船厂时，人群聚集起来看他，你知道的。这种情况在几天内就发生了，他感到非常沮丧。
And he's particularly upset because the youth of the town rather let Holland down, don't they? Because the boys pelt him with mud. Do you see this? Well, but you could say that that's an affirmation of their rugged Republican character. Maybe it is. So he has to hide in an inn and the town's burger master has to issue an order banning people from harassing and
他尤其感到沮丧的是，镇上的年轻人相当让荷兰丢脸，对吧？因为男孩子们用泥巴砸他。你看到这个了吗？嗯，但你也可以说那是他们粗犷的共和主义性格的体现。也许是的。所以他不得不躲进一家小客栈里，镇长不得不发布一项命令，禁止人们骚扰和——
I quote, distinguished persons who wish to remain unknown. That's a nicely phrased. It is. However, it doesn't really work because by the end of the week, he's only been there a week and it's absolutely ludicrous scenes because by now hundreds of people have come from Amsterdam to watch him working. When he gets up in the morning, he opens his front door and there are people sitting on the roofs of the neighboring houses kind of, you know, with picnics waiting to see him.
我引用一下——“希望保持匿名的尊贵人士”。这措辞挺不错的。然而，这并没有什么用，因为到了周末，他才去了一个星期，场面就变得绝对荒谬了，因为此时有数百人从阿姆斯特丹赶来观看他工作。当他早晨起床打开前门时，邻近房屋的屋顶上坐满了人，你知道的，拿着野餐篮等着看他。
Everywhere he goes there are people basically mobbing him and stuff. By Sunday he's become a prisoner in his own cottage and he's very upset about this and eventually he says, right enough. I've given up on Zaandam, I'm going to go to Amsterdam. So he moves to Amsterdam with his entourage and they stay there for four months. He can work in a place that's kind of closed off, isn't it? So nobody, people can't spy him. The Dutch East India Company. Yeah.
他无论走到哪里，人们基本上都在围攻他。到了星期天，他成了自己小屋里的囚徒，他对此非常沮丧，最终他说：“够了。我放弃赞丹了，我要去阿姆斯特丹。”于是他带着随从搬到了阿姆斯特丹，在那里住了四个月。他可以在一个相对封闭的地方工作，对吧？这样就没有人能窥探他了。荷兰东印度公司。是的。
So he would be canceled today for his associations with the Dutch East. Well, not just the beheading. I mean, I think there are other things as well. He'd be canceled. Yeah. The bellows. Yeah. So the Dutch East India Company is, is, is closed off.
所以他如果放到今天，会因为与荷兰东印度公司的关联而被取消资格（cancel）。嗯，不仅仅是因为斩首。我的意思是，我觉得还有其他一些事情。他会被取消资格的。是的。风箱。是的。所以荷兰东印度公司是一个封闭的地方。
The shipyard is barred to the public by these big high walls. And they say to him, look, come and work for us. We'll have a new frigate laid down specially so you can work on it. And you can observe our shipbuilding techniques from start to finish. He shares a house with the other Russians who say they'll come work at the yard with him. He arrives at work every day, like a normal shipbuilder with his tools. He says to everybody, call me Carpenter Peter.
造船厂用这些又高又大的墙把公众挡在外面。他们对他说，看，来为我们工作吧。我们会专门为您建造一艘新的护卫舰，这样您就可以在上面工作了。您可以从头到尾观察我们的造船技术。他和其他俄罗斯人合住一栋房子，这些人说他们会来造船厂和他一起工作。他每天都去上班，像个普通的造船匠一样带着工具。他对每个人说，叫我彼得木匠。
Don't call me, you know, the Tsar or anything like that. And he works hard. It's not just kind of, you know, Mary Antoinette-ing. No, no, no, not at all. Not at all. So when he's not at the shipyard, he goes and meets one of his great heroes, William of Orange, William the third. Who by this point is also the king of England.
不要叫我沙皇什么的。他工作很努力。这不仅仅是那种，你知道的，玛丽·安托瓦内特式的过家家。不，不，不，一点也不。一点也不。所以当他不在造船厂时，他会去见他的一位伟大英雄——奥兰治的威廉，也就是威廉三世。这位威廉三世此时也是英国国王。
Also the king of England. Peter has grown up listening to stories about William of Orange fighting the French and he loves all these stories. He goes to see factories, he goes to laboratories, he goes to museums, he goes to botanical gardens. He's basically absorbing everything that he can. He particularly is very keen on anatomy. He makes all his mates go with him to watch the corpse being dissected. And one of many great lines in the Robert K Massey book, to the horror of the Dutch,
也是英国国王。彼得从小就听着奥兰治的威廉与法国人战斗的故事长大的，他非常喜欢这些故事。他去参观工厂，去实验室，去博物馆，去植物园。他基本上在尽可能地吸收一切。他对解剖学特别感兴趣。他让所有的同伴陪他去观看解剖尸体。引用罗伯特·K·马西（Robert K Massey）书中的许多精彩台词之一，令荷兰人感到惊恐的是，
he ordered his comrades to approach the cadaver, bend down and bite off a muscle of the corpse with their teeth. Oh my God. So yeah, I mean, it's, it's all fun and games with Peter the great. And the other thing he's very keen on is the techniques that are being developed in by Dutch anatomists to preserve corpses. Yeah. He loves all that. So presumably it's not formaldehyde, but yeah, kind of whatever an 18th century equivalent of that 17th century equivalent of that. Well, as we will see, he loves a cabinet of curiosities, doesn't
他命令他的同伴们走近尸体，弯下腰，用牙齿从尸体上咬下一块肌肉。哦，天哪。所以，是的，我是说，彼得大帝的经历总是充满了各种趣事。他非常热衷的另一件事是荷兰解剖学家正在研究的保存尸体的技术。是的。他喜欢这一切。所以这大概不是甲醛，但不管怎样，那大概是17世纪相当于甲醛的东西。好吧，正如我们将看到的，他喜欢聚宝柜，不是吗？
he? He does. And so this is very important for later developments in St. Petersburg. Yeah. So anyway, he finally builds his frigate. The Dutch say we will give this to you as a gift. You can have it shipped to Archangel. They're going to call it the Amsterdam, which is all very nice.
他是。这对于圣彼得堡后来的发展非常重要。是的。所以无论如何，他终于建造了他的护卫舰。荷兰人说，我们将把它作为礼物送给你。你可以把它运到阿尔汉格尔斯克。他们打算把它命名为“阿姆斯特丹”，这都很好。
However, he's a bit disappointed by his time in Holland because the Dutch, when they build a ship, they sort of do it intuitively. They don't have blueprints. They just know what they're doing. They're not big fans of the process. I think it's fair to say. So Peter is in the situation of the Romans in the first Punic War, right? Who have to learn chip building from scratch and like a kind of Ikea kit.
然而，他在荷兰的时光多少有点让他失望，因为荷兰人在建造船只时，有点凭直觉行事。他们没有蓝图。他们只是凭经验做事。他们不太喜欢按流程办事。我想这么说并不过分。所以彼得的处境就像第一次布匿战争中的罗马人一样，对吧？他们必须从零开始学习造船，就像拼宜家家具的套件一样。
That's what he wants. Exactly. He says, come on, do you not have blueprints? And they and they say no we don't but that's not how we do it. They say maybe the english the english and more blueprint people so he says to william can i go and visit your other kingdom please and william says. I'd love nothing better and so on the eighth of january sixteen ninety eight peter set sail for god's own country, for England. Lucky man. And we will be back after the break to find out how he gets on in London. I'm David McClaskey, former CIA analyst turned spy novelist. And I'm Gordon Carrera, national security journalist. And together we're the hosts of The Rest is Classified,
这正是他想要的。没错。他说，得了吧，你们难道没有蓝图吗？他们说，不，我们没有，但我们不是那样干的。他们说，也许英国人，英国人更喜欢看蓝图。所以他对威廉说，我能去参观一下你的另一个王国吗？威廉说，求之不得。因此，在1698年1月8日，彼得起航前往上帝的国土——英国。幸运的家伙。我们将在中场休息后回来，了解他在伦敦的经历。我是戴维·麦克拉斯基，前中情局分析师，现转型为间谍小说家。我是戈登·卡雷拉，国家安全记者。我们一起主持《真相属于最高机密》，
where we bring you brilliant stories from the world of spies. This week we're talking about one of the most significant stories of the 21st century, Edward Snowden, and how he orchestrated the biggest leak of classified secrets in modern American and British history. Snowden revealed that the American government was mass collecting data on its own citizens, and it was really the first time that Americans and so many others around the world understood the extent of the US government's mass surveillance. That's right, it's a story I covered at the time and it really gets to wider questions
在这里，我们将为您讲述来自间谍世界的精彩故事。本周我们讨论的是21世纪最重要的故事之一——爱德华·斯诺登，以及他是如何策划现代美国和英国历史上最大规模的机密泄露事件的。斯诺登披露了美国政府对其自身公民进行的大规模数据收集，这实际上是美国人以及世界各地许多其他人第一次了解到美国政府大规模监控的程度。没错，这是我当时报道过的一个故事，它确实触及了更广泛的问题，
about what privacy means, how technology has changed our lives, and what the government and companies can do with data we might have thought was private. And we'll take you through the whole story from Snowden's early career in the CIA and the NSA to his life in exile in Russia. So to hear more search for The Rest is Classified wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everyone. Welcome back to The Rest is History. Peter the Great is sailing across the channel up the Thames estuary. And on the morning of the 11th of January, 1698,
关于隐私意味着什么，技术如何改变了我们的生活，以及政府和公司如何处理我们原本以为是私密的数据。我们将带您了解整个故事，从斯诺登早年在中情局和国安局的职业生涯，到他在俄罗斯的流亡生活。所以想了解更多，请在您获取播客的任何地方搜索《真相属于最高机密》。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的真相》。彼得大帝正乘船穿过海峡，逆着泰晤士河口向上游驶去。在1698年1月11日的早晨，
he arrives in London. And Dominic, he is rowed ashore to a landing key on the Strand, joining the city of London to Westminster. And there the court chamberlain of William the third, who is also of course back in the Dutch Republic, the Prince of Orange is waiting to greet him and does so in Dutch, which Peter speaks. Yeah. It's great scene, Peter arriving in London.
他抵达了伦敦。多米尼克，他被划船送上岸，到达了河岸街（The Strand）的一个登陆码头，这里连接着伦敦市和威斯敏斯特。威廉三世的宫廷内侍正等在那里迎接他，威廉三世本人当然也回到了荷兰共和国，奥兰治亲王正在等候迎接他，并用彼得会说的荷兰语交谈。是的。这是一个非常棒的场景，彼得抵达伦敦。
London is a big city at this point, 750,000 people. It's a really interesting moment in London's history. Actually this, I think it's, if you're going to go back to London at any point in time this is as good as any because it's still a very kind of raucous disputatious city a city of kind of public flogging and cockfighting and stuff but we're at the point in history where the Bank of England has been created where party politics is starting where England is becoming a maritime kind of commercial empire. So it's interesting, it's coffee houses and newspapers. And a scientific power as well, Isaac Newton and Royal Society and all of that.
当时的伦敦是一座大城市，拥有75万人口。这其实是伦敦历史上一个非常有趣的时刻。如果你要在任何时间点回到伦敦，这个时刻和其他任何时刻一样好，因为它仍然是一座非常喧闹、好争辩的城市，一座充斥着公开鞭刑、斗鸡等活动的城市。但我们正处于历史上的这样一个转折点：英格兰银行已经建立，政党政治正在起步，英格兰正在成为一个海上商业帝国。所以它很有趣，到处都是咖啡馆和报纸。它也是一个科学强国，有艾萨克·牛顿、皇家学会以及所有这些。
Exactly. There's Christopher Wren churches being built. There's all of this stuff. And Peter, when he arrives, he stays in a place called Norfolk Street, which doesn't exist, I think anymore, which is just off the Strand. And basically it's like a student house. He moves in with all his mates into the student house. There's a wonderful historian of Peter the Great, a biographer called Lindsay Hughes, and she describes how the Prince of Denmark heard that he was in town and went to visit
没错。雷恩克里斯托弗（Christopher Wren）的教堂正在建设中。所有这些都在发生。彼得到达后，住在诺福克街（Norfolk Street）的一个地方，我想现在已经不存在了，它就在河岸街旁边。基本上它就像一个学生宿舍。他和他的所有伙伴一起搬进了这个学生宿舍。有一位彼得大帝的杰出历史学家、传记作家叫林赛·休斯（Lindsay Hughes），她描述了丹麦王子听说他在城里并前去拜访的经过，
him and was horrified when he arrived at Peter's house to find Peter still in bed and four other people in the room as well. And, and I quote, they had to open all the windows to clear the terrible stench. They're very student digs. Very student digs. He goes around London. He meets the future Queen Anne at Kensington palace. William the third William of Orange introduces him.
当他到达彼得的房子时，发现彼得还在睡觉，房间里还有另外四个人，这让他感到惊恐万分。我引用原话：“他们不得不打开所有的窗户来驱散那股可怕的恶臭。”这非常符合学生宿舍的风格。非常符合学生宿舍的风格。他在伦敦四处走动。他在肯辛顿宫会见了未来的安妮女王。威廉三世——奥兰治的威廉接待了他。
The Thames is frozen. There's a great frost. So he can't get into shipbuilding straight away. So he goes shopping. He goes to a watchmaker to see how watches work and to get watches. He's very impressed by English coffins. That's good to know. He says, this is brilliant.
泰晤士河结冰了。有一场大寒潮。所以他不能马上涉足造船业。于是他去购物。他去钟表匠那里了解钟表的工作原理并购买手表。他对英国的棺材印象深刻。很高兴知道这一点。他说，这太棒了。
I never imagined people could make coffins like this. He has a coffin shipped specially to Moscow. He buys a swordfish, a stuffed swordfish and a stuffed crocodile. He wants to send them to Moscow as well. So that's testimony to the fact that the English are becoming a polite and commercial people, isn't it? That they have shops where you can buy a stuffed crocodile. Exactly. Our taxidermist is second to none, I think it's fair to say. He becomes friends with a bloke called the Marquis of Carmarthen
我从没想过人们能制作出这样的棺材。他让人专门运送了一口棺材到莫斯科。他买了一条剑鱼，一条塞满填充物的剑鱼和一条塞满填充物的鳄鱼。他也想把它们送到莫斯科。这证明了英国人正在成为一个彬彬有礼的商业民族，不是吗？因为他们有可以买到标本鳄鱼的商店。没错。我们的剥制师首屈一指，我认为这么说并不过分。他和一个叫卡马森侯爵的家伙成为了朋友，
and he goes to the pub with this bloke so often that the pub is renamed the Tsar of Russia. And Carmarthen says, oh, I know who you'd like to meet. And he introduces him to an actress called Latisha cross Who becomes his mistress while he's in England and moves in with him in the student house and what language they speak Is it the language of love the language of love Tom they speak the language of love right? Anyway, he's off the strand. So he's very central and there's more trouble with crowds and so William the third's government say Look, we'll find you a house across the river. And this is where we come to a single favorite episode in all of history.
他经常和这家伙去酒吧，以至于这家伙所在的酒吧被重新命名为“俄罗斯沙皇”。卡马森说，哦，我知道你想见谁。他把他介绍给了一位名叫拉蒂莎·克罗斯（Latisha Cross）的女演员，她在英国期间成了他的情妇，并搬进学生宿舍和他住在一起。他们说的是什么语言？是爱的语言吗？爱的语言，汤姆，他们说的是爱的语言，对吧？无论如何，他离开了河岸街。所以他住在非常中心的地方，人群又出现了一些麻烦，所以威廉三世政府说，听着，我们会在河对岸为你找栋房子。这就是我们来到历史上最受欢迎的单一事件的时候。
Yeah. So the essayist and kind of diarist and whatnot, John Evelyn has this house in Deptford and Charles the second had given John Evelyn a lease on this house and Evelyn had owned it for 45 years and he had set out what was regarded as arguably the greatest garden in England. His pride and joy. It had a bowling green, it had a terrace walk, it had kitchen gardens, it had a walled garden. Now when it was first mentioned to John Evelyn that Peter the Great might move in, he said
是的。所以散文家、日记作家约翰·伊夫林（John Evelyn）在德普福德（Deptford）有这样一栋房子，查理二世曾将这栋房子的租约授予约翰·伊夫林，伊夫林已经拥有它45年了，他规划了被认为可以说是英格兰最伟大的花园。那是他的骄傲和喜悦。它有一个地滚球场，一条露台步道，有菜园，还有一个带围墙的花园。当第一次有人向约翰·伊夫林提及彼得大帝可能会搬进来时，他说，
brilliant because he's actually been renting it to a man called Admiral Benbow. The pub in Treasure Island, as in the pub. Admiral Benbow had not been a good tenant. They'd been a little bit of wear and tear and he hadn't looked after the garden properly. So John even said, Oh, well, great. I mean, these Russians, they can't be any worse than Admiral Benbow. And we will find out later in the episode exactly what went on, but it's very clear something has gone wrong when Tony, after a few days says
太棒了，因为他实际上是把它租给了一个叫本博海军上将（Admiral Benbow）的人。就是《金银岛》里那个酒吧名字来源的本博海军上将。本博海军上将并不是个好房客。房子有一些磨损，他也没有好好打理花园。所以约翰·伊夫林说，哦，太好了。我的意思是，这些俄罗斯人不可能比本博海军上将更糟。我们将在本集的后面了解到具体发生了什么，但很显然，有些事情已经出了问题，当托尼几天后说，
the house is full of people and right nasty, but how nasty we will discover. Anyway, while he's not smashing up the house, we mentioned Bishop Burnett from Wiltshire in the Salisbury area. He's been trying to convert Peter to Anglicanism, but the people that Peter really loves meeting are very much friends of the show. Richard Nixon's favorite people, the Quakers. Always good to have a Quaker on the rest of history. So Peter can't get enough of the Quakers. He goes to prayer meetings. They're Quaking and doing what they do, being very sober and quaking. He says, this is absolutely amazing. Yeah.
房子里挤满了人，而且非常讨厌，但究竟有多讨厌，我们拭目以待。总之，当他不砸坏房子的时候，我们提到了威尔特郡索尔兹伯里地区的伯内特主教。他一直试图把彼得皈依为英国国教徒，但彼得真正喜欢见的人非常符合节目的调性，也就是理查德·尼克松最喜欢的人——贵格会教徒。节目里能有个贵格会教徒总是不错的。所以彼得对贵格会教徒简直爱不释手。他去参加祷告会。他们在颤抖，做着他们常做的事，表现得非常严肃并不断颤抖。他说，这真是太棒了。是的。
I love this. He meets William Penn of Pennsylvania. Well, presumably if they're quaking and Peter is given to convulsions, he'd feel quite at home, wouldn't he? Yeah. He fits in for once. His twitching is not noticed. So William Penn of Pennsylvania fame, he is in between trips to Pennsylvania.
我喜欢这个。他见到了宾夕法尼亚的威廉·佩恩。嗯，如果他们在颤抖，而彼得又容易抽搐，他会感到挺自在的，对吧？是的。他破天荒地融入进去了。他的抽搐没有被注意到。所以那位以宾夕法尼亚闻名的威廉·佩恩，他正处于两次前往宾夕法尼亚的间隙。
He goes to the house of Deptford to talk to Peter and they have a great chat in Dutch about Quakerism and afterwards Peter says to his Russian friends, whoever could live according to such a doctrine would be truly happy. I mean it's amazing isn't it because foreign visitors to London are impressed by the Quakers because Voltaire when he goes to London will be similarly kind of wowed by them. It's kind of interesting. It's clearly Something about London that foreigners find interesting. Yeah, but not in a sort of freak show way, right? No, they're impressed by them. They're impressed by he takes it really seriously He does loads of fun tourist things Yeah
他去了德普福德的房子与彼得交谈，他们用荷兰语就贵格会进行了愉快的交谈，之后彼得对他的俄罗斯朋友说，无论谁能按照这样的教义生活，都会真正幸福。我的意思是这太神奇了，不是吗？因为外国访客对伦敦的贵格会教徒印象深刻，因为伏尔泰去伦敦时也会对他们赞叹不已。这挺有意思的。这显然是伦敦的一些特质，让外国人觉得有趣。是的，但不是那种猎奇的方式，对吧？不，他们对他们印象深刻。他们对印象深刻的是，他非常认真地对待这件事，他做了很多有趣的旅游活动。是的。
He basically follows the itinerary that you would follow if you came to London on holiday now He goes to Greenwich he goes to the Tower of London and they hide the axe with which a child's the first to being Decapitated don't they? Because they're worried that if he finds it, he'll be so outraged he'll fling it in the Thames. Yes. And my favourite tourist thing that he does, he goes to Parliament and he says, I'd love to see it.
他基本上遵循了你现在去伦敦度假时会遵循的路线。他去格林尼治，去伦敦塔，他们把砍掉查理一世脑袋的那把斧头藏了起来，对吧？因为他们担心如果他发现了，他会非常愤怒，并把它扔进泰晤士河。是的。我最喜欢的他做的游客行为是，他去议会参观，他说，我很想看看。
And he doesn't want to draw attention to himself. So he climbs up to the roof and he watches through a kind of upper gallery sort of skylight style window in the roof as William III is giving a cent to tax bills in the house of Lords. And he says afterwards to his friends and whatnot, he says, well, we obviously couldn't do this in Russia because you know, we have the absolute power of the czar in Russia. We couldn't have any limitations. However, and I quote, it is good to hear subjects speaking truthfully and openly to their king. This is what we must learn from the English. Now there's a lesson here for Vladimir Putin, isn't there?
他不想引起人们对他的注意。于是他爬上屋顶，通过屋顶上一种类似于天窗的窗户，从上层的画廊往下看，看着威廉三世在上议院批准税收法案。事后他对他的朋友们说，我们显然不能在俄罗斯这样做，因为你知道，我们在俄罗斯拥有沙皇的绝对权力。我们不能有任何限制。然而，我引述原话，“听到臣民对他们的国王讲真话和实话，这很好。这是我们必须向英国人学习的地方。”这给弗拉基米尔·普京上了一课，不是吗？
Well, just on the topic of Vladimir Putin and London and Peter the Great. Oh yeah. I don't know if you've seen there's a statue of Peter the Great at Deptford. Yes. Very weird done by the sculptor who also did one that was put up in the Peter and Paul fortress in St. Petersburg. The sculptor is very keen on portraying Peter with very long elongated fingers and limbs. So he looks very peculiar. And a small head. Yes. So both those statues and the statue in Deptford was set up at the beginning of the 21st century. And Putin, when he came to London, went to visit it and he was escorted by Prince Andrew.
关于弗拉基米尔·普京、伦敦和彼得大帝的话题。哦，是的。我不知道你是否见过，德普福德有一尊彼得大帝的雕像。是的。非常奇怪，是由那个还在圣彼得堡彼得保罗要塞创作了一尊雕像的雕塑家制作的。这位雕塑家非常热衷于将彼得描绘成有着非常长、细长的手指和四肢。所以他看起来非常奇特。还有一个小脑袋。是的。所以这两座雕像以及德普福德的雕像都是在21世纪初竖立起来的。普京来伦敦时，曾去参观过它，是由安德鲁王子陪同的。
Wow, there's a couple. There's an interesting episode from history. Yeah, so I looked up what it actually said on the statue and it said, This monument is erected near the Royal Shipyard where Peter the Great studied the English science of shipbuilding. The monument is a gift from the Russian people and commemorates the visit of Peter the Great to this country in search of knowledge and experience. Oh, so that's nice. Well, Peter did get knowledge and experience to be fair.
哇，真是绝配。这是历史上的一个有趣插曲。是的，所以我查了一下雕像上实际写的内容，上面写着：“这座纪念碑竖立在皇家造船厂附近，彼得大帝曾在这里学习英国的造船科学。这座纪念碑是俄罗斯人民的礼物，旨在纪念彼得大帝为寻求知识和经验而访问这个国家。”哦，这挺好的。嗯，公平地说，彼得确实获得了知识和经验。
I'll tell you one thing he picked up was smoking. Smoking previously banned in Russia, except in the German suburb. He signs a deal with this bloke, Carmarthen, that he goes drinking with so that Carmarthen can import tobacco to Russia. And also he does manage to get about 60 mathematicians, shipwrights, engineers, and he persuades them to come back with him to Russia as well as to Barber's right. So his westernizing brain is ticking over. Exactly.
我告诉你他学会的一件事就是抽烟。吸烟以前在俄罗斯是被禁止的，除了在德国人郊区。他与这个经常和他一起喝酒的家伙卡马森达成了一项协议，这样卡马森就可以向俄罗斯进口烟草。他还成功弄到了大约60名数学家、造船匠、工程师，并说服他们和他一起回俄罗斯，还有理发师。所以他西化的头脑正在飞速运转。没错。
So the 2nd of May, he says, look, I've been here for ages. It's time to go on. He loved England. We're used to the Russians being incredibly disobliging about our beloved country, aren't we? Well, I don't know. I mean, wealthy Russians, they tend to like London. They like our football clubs.
所以在5月2日，他说，听着，我在这里待了很久了。是时候继续前程了。他喜欢英国。我们习惯了俄罗斯人对我们深爱的国家表现得极为冷淡，不是吗？嗯，我不知道。我的意思是，富有的俄罗斯人往往喜欢伦敦。他们喜欢我们的足球俱乐部。
That's true. They like our Bijou West End houses. Nationalist commentators are always going on Russian state television, aren't they? And sort of doing mock-ups of how Britain would be annihilated by a nuclear weapon. Or a tsunami. Or a tsunami, exactly. But Peter the Great would not have approved of that because he told a captain later, he said it would be a much happier life to be an Admiral in England than a Tsar in Russia.
这倒也是。他们喜欢我们在西区的高级住宅。民族主义评论员总是上俄罗斯国家电视台，不是吗？然后制作英国如何被核武器消灭的模拟画面。或者海啸。或者海啸，完全正确。但彼得大帝不会赞同这一点，因为他后来告诉一位船长，他说在英国当一名海军上将，要比在俄罗斯当沙皇幸福得多。
I mean, I'm so happy to be quoting this. He said England is the best, the most beautiful and the happiest place on earth. So although he's a brutal and murderous autocrat, he's clearly not all bad. No, he's a man of tremendous taste. Now, sadly, not all Englishmen are as keen on Peter the Great as he is on them. Because as soon as he's left, John Evelyn goes to see what's happened to his house. And it is most nasty. And it was very nasty. He's so appalled he then goes straight to the Royal Surveyor, Sir Christopher Wren and the Royal Gardener who's a man called Mr London, and he says come to my house immediately. You know the government's going to have to compensate me
我的意思是，我很高兴能引用这句话。他说英国是世界上最好、最美丽、最幸福的地方。所以尽管他是一个残暴嗜杀的独裁者，但他显然并非一无是处。不，他是一个极有品味的人。现在，遗憾的是，并非所有英国人都像他对他们那样对彼得大帝感兴趣。因为他一走，约翰·伊夫林就去看看他的房子变成了什么样。结果简直糟透了。而且确实非常糟糕。他震惊得直接去找皇家测量师克里斯托弗·雷恩爵士和皇家园丁——一个叫伦敦先生的人，他说，马上来我的房子。你知道政府得赔偿我，
for this. And when they get there they find it has been utterly trashed. Ink everywhere, grease everywhere. All the door knobs and locks have been pried off. The windows have been smashed. The chairs have all been smashed up and used as firewood. The pictures have been ripped up and the garden, Avery's Pride and Joy, the greatest garden in England, absolutely destroyed. The claim is is I think
因为这个。当他们到达那里时，他们发现房子已经被彻底砸烂了。到处都是墨水，到处都是油脂。所有的门把手和锁都被撬掉了。窗户被砸碎了。椅子全被砸碎当成了柴火。画作被撕毁了，花园——伊夫林的骄傲和喜悦，英格兰最伟大的花园——被彻底毁了。据称，我想，
there's some dispute among sort of scholars about whether this is invented or not, that they'd been having wheelbarrow races through the hedges. So to quote, the lawn was trampled into mud and dust as if a regiment of soldiers in iron shoes had drilled on it. And who knows? I mean, Peter loves a fake army. So maybe they've done that. The magnificent Holly hedge had been flattened by wheelbarrows rammed through it so presumably that's where
学者们对这是否是编造的还有一些争议，他们在树篱间进行过独轮车比赛。引述原话，“草坪被踩成泥土和灰尘，就像一团穿着铁鞋的士兵连队在上面操练过一样。”谁知道呢？我的意思是，彼得喜欢假军队。所以也许他们真的那样做了。壮丽的冬青树篱被独轮车撞穿，夷为平地，所以大概这就是那个故事的由来。完全正确，完全正确。政府最终赔偿了约翰·伊夫林350多英镑，如果你用“测量价值”（Measuring Worth）网站上的计算器来算——那是我经常使用的网站，因为它是最复杂的——这基本上折合今天的收入超过100万英镑，
that story comes from exactly exactly and the government ended up paying john even more than three hundred and fifty pounds in compensation which if you use the calculators at the website measuring worth which is the one i always use because it's the most sophisticated that's basically an earnings terms more than a million pounds today that That everyone was given as compensation. That tells you just how much damage there was. So, um, Peter and that by now is long gone. He goes to Dresden. He goes to Vienna and Dominic in Dresden. Crucially, he, he sees the Kunstkammer museum, doesn't he? Yeah.
作为赔偿金交给了伊夫林。这说明了当时造成的破坏有多大。所以，嗯，彼得当时已经离开很久了。他去了德累斯顿。他去了维也纳，而在德累斯顿的多米尼克。关键是，他参观了艺术珍品馆（Kunstkammer）博物馆，不是吗？是的。
Which is a cabinet of curiosities. And so we talked about how in the Netherlands, Peter had seen ways to preserve corpses and now he's seen a cabinet of curiosities. And so we talked about how in the Netherlands, Peter had seen ways to preserve corpses. And now he's seen the cabinet of curiosities. And this is setting up, again, all kinds of ideas in his fertile and faintly dark brain. Exactly. Exactly. So he has a nice time in Vienna. And then he's preparing to move on to Venice in July when bombshell news he has a letter from Moscow from his mate Romanovsky. Terrible things have been happening in Russia. Four regiments of Streltsy were being transferred from the Sea of Azov to the Polish frontier and they have mutinied. They are now marching on Moscow and they are only 60 miles away.
这是一个百宝箱。所以我们谈到在荷兰，彼得见识了保存尸体的方法，现在他又看到了一个百宝箱。所以我们谈到在荷兰，彼得见识了保存尸体的方法。现在他看到了百宝箱。这再次在他肥沃且隐带黑暗的大脑中勾勒出各种各样的主意。没错。没错。所以他在维也纳过得很愉快。然后在7月份准备动身前往威尼斯时，传来了一个重磅新闻：他收到了来自莫斯科的信，寄信人是他的密友罗马诺夫斯基。俄罗斯发生了可怕的事情。斯特烈齐（Streltsy，俄国近卫军）的四个团正从亚速海调往波兰边境，他们哗变了。他们现在正向莫斯科进军，而且距离只有60英里远。
And of course this letter has taken a long time to reach Peter. Peter can't believe it. So what this means is that while he's been messing around with Cabinets of Curaustis in Dresden and dancing at balls in Vienna, the Streltsy may well have taken Moscow. He may have been deposed and proclaimed a traitor. He says, oh my God. So he scraps his plan. The gap year is over, and he rushes east and he's riding through Poland day and night, stopping only to change horses.
当然，这封信花了很长时间才送到彼得手中。彼得简直不敢相信。这意味着，当他在德累斯顿摆弄百宝箱、在维也纳的舞会上跳舞时，斯特烈齐很可能已经占领了莫斯科。他可能已经被废黜并宣告为叛徒。他说，哦，天哪。于是他取消了计划。间隔年结束了，他日夜兼程地向东骑马赶回，中途只停下来换马。
And then he gets to crack off and another messenger comes riding up from the east. And Peter sort of rips open the message. A massive sigh of relief. Romanovsky reports that their troops have intercepted and defeated the Streltsy rebels. Although he's going to carry on going home, he can slow down a bit and he heads to meet somebody who will play a big part in the story who is Augustus the Strong. And you love him, don't you? I love Augustus the Strong.
然后他到了克拉科夫（Cracow），另一个信使从东方骑马赶来。彼得撕开信件。长舒了一口气。罗马诺夫斯基报告说，他们的军队已经拦截并击败了斯特烈齐叛军。尽管他还要继续赶回家，但他可以放慢一点速度，他前往去见一个将在故事中扮演重要角色的人，那就是强者奥古斯都。你很喜欢他，不是吗？我喜欢强者奥古斯都。
He's one of your favourite characters from all of history. He is. So he was the elector of Saxony, Augustus, and he'd been elected King of Poland and Grand Duke of Lithuania in 1698. And we said we'd get into the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth. It's this great sort of ramshackle state of 8 million people, vast, culturally fascinating, a real mix of Catholics, Jews and whatnot, fascinating kind of mosaic. Even Muslims. Even Muslims, exactly.
他是你最喜欢的历史人物之一。他是。所以他是萨克森选帝侯奥古斯都，在1698年当选为波兰国王和立陶宛大公。我们说过我们会谈谈波兰立陶宛联邦。这是一个拥有800万人口的宏大、散乱的国家，幅员辽阔，文化迷人，是天主教徒、犹太人等的真正大熔炉，一种迷人的马赛克拼图。甚至还有穆斯林。甚至还有穆斯林，完全正确。
Because there are Muslims who've been settled there. Sort of heretics of various kinds go there because it's so tolerant. It's sort of an experiment in multiculturalism in some ways, but it's beginning to fall apart a bit and it's got a bonkers political system. Because diversity is not necessarily its strength. It's not its strength, I think it's beginning to fall apart a bit and it's got a bonkers political system because diversity is not necessarily it's not its strength I think it's fair to say now Augustus has been elected to rule this this kingdom He's a gigantic man like Peter's like a he looks like a bear his party trick. Well, he has multiple party tricks He likes to amuse his courtiers by snapping horseshoes with one hand
因为那里定居着一些穆斯林。各种各样的异端也去那里，因为它太宽容了。在某种程度上，这是一种多元文化的实验，但它开始有点分崩离析，而且它的政治体制非常疯狂。因为多样性不一定是它的优势。这不是它的优势，我认为这么说并不过分。现在奥古斯都当选统治这个王国。他身材魁梧，就像彼得一样，他看起来像头熊，他的拿手绝活。好吧，他有很多拿手绝活。他喜欢通过单手捏碎马蹄来逗乐他的朝臣。
They do that, but he does it anyway. Presumably with fingers. It's reflection on the strength of his fingers, I guess. As fingers, you could just snap your fingers and snap a horseshoe. Maybe. Yeah, I guess. If you're just doing it with one hand. He loves collecting porcelain. He has dozens of mistresses.
他们会那样做，但他无论如何都会这么做。大概是用手指。我猜这反映了他手指的力量。作为手指，你可以打个响指就把马蹄捏碎。也许吧。是的，我猜。如果你只是用单手做的话。他喜欢收集瓷器。他有很多情妇。
He fathered 354 illegitimate children, which I think is a lot. Wow. He collected lions, hyenas, monkeys and meerkats. Meerkats. Yeah. Meerkats. Is he the first European Royal to collect a meerkat? I think it probably is.
他生了354个私生子，我觉得这挺多的。哇。他收集狮子、鬣狗、猴子和猫鼬。猫鼬。是的。猫鼬。他是第一个收集猫鼬的欧洲皇室成员吗？我想可能是的。
They were always shipping animals to him and they'd open the box and the animal would be dead. That was the usual scenario. It was pretty tough on the animals. And he's not one of history's great animal lovers because his real, you know real party piece his specialism the thing for which he goes down in history is he's probably history's most proficient fox tosser so If you interested in tossing a fox Augustus the strong is the absolute model right so once when he was receiving the king of Prussia to greet the king, he tossed 200
人们总是给他运送动物，等他们打开箱子时，动物已经死了。那是通常的场景。这对动物来说挺残酷的。他不是历史上伟大的动物爱好者之一，因为他真正的、你知道的真正的拿手好戏，他的专长，他名留青史的事情是，他可能是历史上最熟练的“抛狐狸”高手。所以如果你对抛狐狸感兴趣，强者奥古斯都就是绝对的楷模。有一次他接待普鲁士国王以迎接国王时，他抛了200只狐狸、
foxes, six wildcats, two batches and two beavers. And when I say tossed, he tossed them to their deaths. That's what he does. Oh my God. So basically his servants will line up with these beavers and badgers. He just grabs them, throws them up in the air, throws them in the air so high that they come crashing down to earth and die. It's like brilliant.
6只野猫、2只獾和2只海狸。当我说抛时，他是把它们抛死。这就是他所做的。哦，天哪。所以基本上他的仆人们会排队拿着这些海狸和獾。他只是抓住它们，把它们扔到空中，把它们扔得那么高，以至于它们猛烈坠落地面而死。这太棒了。
So he doesn't catch them. No, but they splattered over the ceiling surely does this outdoors Oh, right. Okay. So you go into the garden. There's a menagerie there all lined up Just throwing foxes around I mean it seems bonkers hurrah for your majesty Yeah, the late 17th early 18th century. This is very high class entertainment. So don't knock it. And actually, to be fair, let's not knock it until we've done it because we've never tried it or seen it.
所以他不接住它们。不，但它们肯定溅得到处都是，天花板上都是，他是咋做的，在户外的吧？哦，对吧。好吧。所以你走到花园里。那里有一个动物园，所有的动物都排好队。只是把狐狸扔来扔去。我的意思是，这看起来太疯狂了，陛下万岁！是的，17世纪末18世纪初。这是非常高档的娱乐活动。所以别挑剔它。而且，公平地说，在我们尝试或看到它之前，先别挑剔。
Peter loves this. Of course he does very much his thing, isn't it? Well, the strong will throw a beaver to his death and then Peter will embrace it and kiss him and say, oh, you're brilliant. I love this. I love you. Does Peter have a go at fox tossing? I don't know that he does actually.
彼得喜欢这个。当然，这很符合他的作风，不是吗？嗯，强者奥古斯都会把一只海狸抛死，然后彼得会拥抱并亲吻他，说，哦，你太棒了。我喜欢这个。我爱你。彼得会尝试抛狐狸吗？我不知道他到底有没有试过。
Maybe he would use his bellows or something. I mean, it seems very much his kind of sport. I'd like to think he tried his hand at it, wouldn't you? Yeah. He'd try to toss a bear probably knowing him. Peter said to his nobleman, I prize Augustus more than the whole of you put together, not because he's a king, but merely because I like him. Which is quite
也许他会用他的风箱什么的。我的意思是，这非常符合他的运动风格。我愿意认为他曾亲手试过，不是吗？是的。了解他的话，他可能会试图抛一头熊。彼得对他的贵族说，我珍视奥古斯都胜过你们所有人加起来，不是因为他是国王，而仅仅是因为我喜欢他。这挺温馨的。
sweet. And actually, in between killing all these animals, Augustus takes the opportunity to pitch an idea to Peter that will have massive, massive long-term political consequences. Because both of them hate and fear their northern neighbors, the Swedes. They can't stand the Swedes. The Swedes, the most formidable and modern military power in Northern Europe. And Augustus says, listen, the Swedish king has died,
事实上，在杀死所有这些动物的间隙，奥古斯都借此机会向彼得提出一个将产生巨大、长远政治后果的想法。因为他们俩都痛恨并恐惧他们的北方邻居——瑞典人。他们无法忍受瑞典人。瑞典人是北欧最强大、最现代的军事力量。奥古斯都说，听着，瑞典国王已经死了，
and his successor, who's a bloke called Charles XII, he's a total nobody. He's only 15. He's a teenager. Let's join forces against the Swedes and divide up their Baltic Empire between us. And Peter, who we know loves Augustus the Strong, says, you know, that sounds brilliant because actually my war against the Ottomans is a complete non-event, total damp squib.
他的继承人是一个叫查理十二世的家伙，他完全是个无名小卒。他只有15岁。他还是个十几岁的孩子。让我们联合起来对抗瑞典人，在我们之间瓜分他们的波罗的海帝国。彼得，我们知道他喜欢强者奥古斯都，他说，你知道，这听起来很棒，因为实际上我对奥斯曼帝国的战争完全是一场闹剧，彻底的哑炮。
I'm never going to beat the Ottomans. Forget the Black Sea and we'll move on to the Baltic. Let's keep working on this idea and one day let's do it. Now in the meantime, he has to go back to Moscow, which he does. He goes back to Moscow with all his kind of shipwrights and whatnot and all his sort of is fired with enthusiasm for his westernizing project. He goes to his estate at Praia Brzezanskoye. Very good.
我永远也打不败奥斯曼人。忘掉黑海吧，我们转向波罗的海。让我们继续研究这个想法，总有一天我们把它干了。现在与此同时，他必须回莫斯科，他也确实回去了。他带着他所有的造船匠之类的人回到了莫斯科，他心中燃起了对他西化工程的热情。他去了他在普列奥布拉任斯科耶（Praia Brzezanskoye）的庄园。非常好。
I was looking forward to that. I could see it looming in the notes. I thought, okay, I've just got to go for it. Yeah. And he arrives on the night of the 4th of September 1698. And the next day, the fifth, all his noblemen say, oh, brilliant, you're back. They come to go and greet him. He embraces them. He kisses them.
我一直很期待这个。我看到它在笔记中若隐若现。我想，好吧，我只能硬着头皮上了。是的。他在1698年9月4日的晚上抵达。第二天也就是5号，他所有的贵族都说，哦，太棒了，你回来了。他们来迎接他。他拥抱了他们。他亲吻了他们。
And then out of his back pocket, he pulls out a razor. And then just starts shaving them, cutting off their beards. They are so stunned. They don't know how to react. And he's like very violently, forcibly shaving them. Now the thing is, we did an whole episode, didn't we, about beards and about this business. And for people who missed it, to very briefly explain, to Orthodox Russians, the beard was a gift from God. And to shave it was a sin.
然后从后裤兜里掏出一把剃须刀。接着就开始给他们刮胡子，割掉他们的胡子。他们惊呆了。他们不知道该如何反应。而他就像非常暴力、强行地给他们刮胡子。事情是这样的，我们做过一整集节目，不是吗？关于胡子和这件事。对于错过的人，简要解释一下，对正统的俄罗斯人来说，胡子是上帝的礼物。刮胡子是一种罪过。
Ivan the Terrible had specifically said, it's a sin that the blood of all the martyrs cannot cleanse because it is to deface the image of man created by God. And Peter says, no, this is nonsense. A beard is backwards and he makes everybody shave off their beards. And in the long run, if you want to have a beard, you have to pay a special tax and you get a medallion with a picture of a beard on it. I love that. And then you're allowed to have a beard.
伊凡雷帝曾明确说过，这是一宗连所有烈士的鲜血都无法洗刷的罪过，因为那是玷污了上帝创造的人类形象。彼得说，胡说八道。胡子是落后的，他让每个人都刮掉胡子。长远来看，如果你想留胡子，你必须缴纳特殊的税，并获得一枚印有胡子图案的徽章。我喜欢这个。然后你就可以留胡子了。
And this is just one of a host of changes. So basically up to this point, Russian nobleman had worn these caftans, floppy colored boots, very exotic garb. But also appropriate to the cold weather. Right. I mean, it does keep you warm, right? Also layers. They believe in layers.
这只是一系列变革之一。所以基本上到目前为止，俄罗斯贵族一直穿着这种长袍（caftans）、软底靴子，非常异国情调的服装。但也适合寒冷的天气。对吧？我的意思是，它确实能让你保暖，对吧？还有分层穿衣。他们相信多层穿衣。
Peter does not believe in that. He says this is backwards. Again, it's Asiatic. It's not right. He cuts the sleeves of people's robes off. Like you turn up to a state reception or something. Peter the Great will come at you with a razor and a pair of scissors, probably Dutch or English scissors, and will be cutting off bits of your clothing.
彼得不相信这一点。他说这是落后的。再次强调，这是亚洲式的。这不对。他剪掉了人们长袍的袖子。就像你盛装出席国宴什么的。彼得大帝会拿着剃须刀和一把剪刀向你走来，可能是荷兰或英国的剪刀，然后会剪掉你衣服的一部分。
He says, I want people to wear what they call French or German style coats. He says, I want to see waistcoats. I want to see britches. I want women to wear bonnets and skirts, all of this kind of thing. What about corsets? If you go to Moscow, they hang up models of the approved costumes. And Peter says, when people are coming into the city, the guards have to have pairs of scissors as well.
他说，我想让人们穿他们所谓的法式或德式大衣。他说，我想要看到马甲。我想要看到马裤。我想要女人戴软帽和穿裙子，所有这类事情。胸衣呢？如果你去莫斯科，他们会挂出获批服装的模型。彼得说，当人们进城时，守卫也必须带着剪刀。
And if people are wearing long caftans, the guards will cut the snip, snip, snip, snip exactly. So it obviously didn't work among the great mass of the population at all. But among the elite, it did because foreign ambassadors say that by the mid, the middle of the sort of first decade of the 18th century at balls and at banquets and things people will be dressing in the German manner. I must have been so cold though. Imagine you know your stockings and your britches and the icy wind from the Urals. Yeah but that's fine but I mean would you rather do that or would you rather take your
如果人们穿着长袍，守卫就会咔嚓、咔嚓、咔嚓地剪掉它们，完全如此。所以这在广大普通民众中显然完全行不通。但在精英阶层中行得通，因为外国大使说，到18世纪头十年的中期左右，在舞会、宴会和其他场合，人们会以德国方式着装。那一定很冷吧。想象一下，你知道你的长袜和马裤，以及来自乌拉尔山的冰冷寒风。是的，但这没关系，但我的意思是，你愿意那样做，还是愿意去碰一碰
chances with Peter the Great, Eraser, Scissors? No I wouldn't I mean it's an invidious choice. It's not the only thing he changes. He changes the calendar. So up till this point, the Russians have dated time from the creation of the world. And Peter says, well, that's rubbish. Let's do it from Jesus's birth, like everybody else does in Europe. So they adopt the Julian calendar. They don't really have very good coinage. They were just using bits of other people's coins.
彼得大帝的剃须刀、剪刀？不，我不会，我的意思是这是一个艰难的选择。这不是他改变的唯一事情。他改变了日历。所以在此之前，俄罗斯人是以世界的创造来计算时间的。彼得说，这简直是无稽之谈。像欧洲其他人一样，从耶稣诞生开始算起吧。于是他们采用了儒略历。他们没有很好的铸币。他们只是使用别人硬币的碎片。
They'd kind of cut up. And he says, come on. He loves the English coinage. Cause he'd studied the mint, hadn't he? In the tower of London, he'd been to the mint. Exactly. He says you must have coinage just like the English do now for him. Personally, there's a big change as well.
他们把它们切碎。他说，得了吧。他喜欢英国的铸币。因为他研究过造币厂，不是吗？在伦敦塔里，他去过造币厂。没错。他说你们必须拥有像英国人现在拥有的那样的铸币。对他个人而言，也有了一个巨大的改变。
And all the time he'd been gone 18 months. He had not written once to his wife. You don't care So people may remember from the last episode. She's pink. Yes pink hopeless and helpless. I think was the description Yeah, he sees her as the embodiment of conservatism and orthodoxy and while he's been away. He's obviously thought to himself I can't stand her. She's got to go. So he basically summons her. She's like, oh great your home and he says well I am. You've got to go. I'm afraid you're off to a nunnery. And he takes his son, Alexis from her and gives him to his sister.
在他离开的这18个月里。他一次也没有给他的妻子写过信。你不在乎。所以大家可能还记得上一集。她是帕多克娅（Eudoxia）。是的，帕多克娅无望且无助。当时的描述大概是这样。是的，他视她为保守主义和东正教的化身。当他不在的时候，他显然心里想：我受够她了。她必须走。所以他基本上把她召了回来。她就像，哦太好了你回家了。他说，好吧，我是回来了。你得走。恐怕你要去修道院了。他把儿子阿列克谢从她身边带走，交给了他的姐姐。
And this is, we will see in our final episode of this series is a very traumatic moment for young Alexis and their relationship will be difficult. I think it's fair to say. It's so interesting, isn't it? We've had so many series recently where unwanted women get packed off to nunneries. So it happened in our series on the Franks happened in our series on the road to 1066. Yeah. We've also had Japanese women going off and becoming nuns.
正如我们将在本系列的最后一集中看到的，这是年轻的阿列克谢非常痛苦的时刻，他们的关系将很艰难，我想这么说并不过分。这太有趣了，不是吗？我们最近有这么多剧集，其中不受欢迎的女人被打包送去修道院。所以在我们关于法兰克人的系列剧里发生过，在我们通往1066之路的系列剧里也发生过。是的。我们还看到日本女性出家当修女。
So very much a theme. It is. And poor Audie Docus, she was forced into a carriage and sent to a convent in Suzdal and her head was shaved. So like the Japanese. Exactly and she was renamed Helen and she had to become a nun with the name of Helen. Now of course he has come home because he's heard about this mutiny among the Streltsy. The people who had you know carried out that horrendous massacre in front of him when he
所以这非常像一个主题。确实如此。可怜的帕多克娅，她被强行塞进一辆马车，送到苏兹达尔（Suzdal）的一座修道院，她的头发被剃光了。就像日本人那样。完全正确，她被改名为海伦，她不得不以海伦的名字成为一名修女。当然，他之所以回家，是因为他听说斯特烈齐发生了这场哗变。那些曾经当着他的面制造了那场可怕大屠杀的人，当时他
was 10 years old and he is clearly determined that he will use this as a pretext to finish them off forever. There's a really a paranoid side, I think to Peter, he reminds me of Henry the eighth, you know, an insecurity in Henry the eighth case, I guess it's because, you know, his father won the throne of Bosworth on the battlefield. And he's always worried about the dynasty and Peter's case is because he had to fight. Right. I mean, just because you're paranoid doesn't mean people aren't out to get you. No.
10岁，他显然决心以此为借口永远消灭他们。我认为彼得身上有一种非常偏执的一面，他让我想起亨利八世，你知道，在亨利八世的案例中是不安全感，我猜是因为，你知道，他的父亲在博斯沃思战役中赢得了王位。他总是担心王朝，而彼得的情况是因为他必须战斗。好吧，但这并不意味着人们没有密谋害你。不。
And he is determined to make a massive example of the mutineers and to show that he believes that this is part of a massive conspiracy orchestrated by his sister Sophia, who's of course in a nunnery herself. And so he has all the mutineers brought to his estate at Praia Brazhanskoye. There you go, Tom. Loving it. I'm just going to do it unnecessarily now. Even when it's not relevant. I'm probably not even pronouncing it correctly, to be honest.
他决心给哗变者一个严厉的教训，并表明他相信这是由他的姐姐索菲亚策划的大规模阴谋的一部分，索菲亚当然她自己也在修道院里。于是他把所有的哗变者都带到他在普列奥布拉任斯科耶的庄园。好了，汤姆。我很喜欢。我只是现在忍不住要多念几次。即使在它不相关的时候。说实话，我可能连发音都不正确。
And at his estate, this is the dark side of Peter. He commissions his men to build 14 special torture chambers. So they bring the mutineers and every week for six days a week, the Streltsy mutineers are interrogated. They are beaten with sticks. They're roasted over open fires. And above all, they are lashed with a thing called the knout, which is this massive leather whip 25 strokes of
在彼得的庄园里，这是他黑暗的一面。他命令手下建造了 14 个专门的酷刑室。他们把哗变士兵带到这里，一周有六天，斯特列尔齐（Streltsy）哗变者都要接受审讯。他们被棍棒殴打，在明火上炙烤，最重要的是，他们被一种叫做“克瑙特”（knout）的巨型皮鞭抽打，25 下这种
the canal will kill you and it literally kind of rips the skin from your back and it's kind of like an assembly line and Peter and his friends and his cronies and his jolly company are the people doing the torturing so not so jolly now not jolly now and he would absolutely join in and he will be beating these people with an ivory handled cane and it's so violent that the patriarch actually says to Peter this is too much stop and Peter is livid about this and he says to the patriarch no Russian society is infected with the disease and I am burning it out and Actually what he gets out of the Streltsy, they confess and they say we'd planned to
皮鞭就能要了你的命，它简直能把你的皮从背上撕下来，这有点像一条流水线，彼得、他的朋友们、他的亲信以及他的快乐同伴们就是施刑的人。所以现在一点也不快乐了，一点也不快乐了。他会绝对参与其中，用一根象牙柄的手杖殴打这些人，场面极其暴力，以至于大主教实际上对彼得说这太过分了，停手吧。彼得对此大发雷霆，他对大主教说，不，俄罗斯社会已经病入膏肓，而我正在将其付之一炬。实际上，他从斯特列尔齐那里得到了供词，他们承认他们曾计划
storm the capital. We were going to burn down the German suburb, we were going to get rid of the foreigners and we were going to get Sophia to rule over us again. But is there any truth to this? Because I mean, I guess they're just saying whatever. Yeah, they're saying what he wants to. Sophia almost certainly didn't know about this, right? It's not that she had instigated the plot, but Peter has never forgiven her. He goes and interrogates her person at her convent. He says
突袭首都。我们要烧毁德国人聚居区，我们要赶走外国人，我们要让索菲娅重新统治我们。但这其中有什么真实性吗？因为我的意思是，我猜他们只是随便说说。是的，他们在说他想听的话。索菲娅几乎肯定不知道这件事，对吧？这并不是她煽动了阴谋，但彼得从未原谅过她。他去她的修道院审问她，他说
her head must be shaved, she must take religious vows and become a nun, and she basically is locked away and is never seen again. She dies when she's 47, 1704. She had previously, of course, been in the nunnery, but had been relatively well treated. And now she's effectively a political prisoner. And that's not the end of it. So Peter is determined. And here I think you see, you know, loads of countries have a violent history or a history of they have show trials or whatever. I mean, we've done series on the French Revolution and whatnot.
她的头必须被剃光，她必须发宗教誓言并成为一名修女，她基本上被软禁起来，再也没有露面。她在 1704 年去世，享年 47 岁。当然，她以前也曾在修道院里，但待遇相对较好。而现在，她实际上成了一个政治犯。事情还没完。因此，彼得下定决心。在这里我认为你可以看到，你知道，许多国家都有暴力历史，或者有作秀审判之类的历史。我的意思是，我们做过关于法国大革命及其他内容的系列节目。
But there's a definite theme, I think, in Russian history of a kind of a fear of enemies within and a conspiracy and a foreign influence and a belief in show trials and public punishment. Yeah. Well show executions as well. Show executions. So he says, well, the Streltsy, you know, they've got to go and hundreds of them are arrested brought in in carts to his estate at Praia Brajanskoye and they are
但俄罗斯历史上确实有一个明确的主题，那就是对内敌、阴谋和外国影响的恐惧，以及对作秀审判和公开惩罚的信仰。是的。还有公开处决。公开处决。所以他说，好吧，斯特列尔齐，你知道，他们必须死，成百上千的人被捕，用大车运到他在普里拉布拉扬斯科耶（Preobrazhenskoye）的庄园，他们
hanged on a special gibbet in front of a crowd. Others are beheaded over an open trench. Quite a few are broken on the wheel aren't they, which is a hideous death. In Red Square, yeah, and actually a really sort of chilling thing. About 200 of them are taken to the convent, Novo Dvichy convent, where Sophia is locked up. And Peter has the most prominent members hanged and strung up outside her window. And they are dangling there. One of them is holding a piece of paper and that's meant to symbolize their petition that they were going to issue, asking her to rule over them. And they are left to hang there outside her window all winter kind of just dangling kind of swaying in the wind.
在一群人面前被吊死在一个特殊的绞刑架上。其他人则在一个开阔的战壕上被砍头。相当多的人被绑在车轮上处决，对吧，这是一种可怕的死亡方式。在红场，是的，而且实际上是一件非常令人不寒栗的事情。大约 200 人被带到索菲娅被关押的圣母新修道院（Novo-Devichy convent）。彼得让人把最显赫的成员吊死在她窗外。他们就在那里摇晃着。其中一个人手里拿着一张纸，这象征着他们原本要发布的请愿书，要求她统治他们。他们就这样被挂在她窗外整个冬天，摇摇晃晃，随风摆动。
And when she whenever she looks out the window there they are. I mean you can only imagine how horrific the sight stench or whatever that must have been for her. I mean actually that isn't the most shocking thing. The most shocking thing is he says he insists that all his friends take part in the executions. So there's an Austrian diplomat who actually describes Peter himself wielding the axe, beheading five people, you know, in public so that everybody can see. I mean, an incredibly gruesome scene. So he did it, Dominic, but was he right to do it? Well, Robert K. Massey, his biographer, he doesn't say he was, but he says this was a
每当她向窗外望去，他们就在那里。我的意思是，你可以想象这对于她来说是多么可怕的景象、恶臭或其他什么。事实上，这并不是最令人震惊的事情。最令人震惊的是，他说他坚持让所有的朋友都参与处决。所以有一位奥地利外交官实际描述了彼得亲自挥舞斧头，公开斩首了五个人，让所有人都看到。我的意思是，一个极其可怕的场景。所以他这样做了，多米尼克，但他这样做对吗？嗯，他的传记作家罗伯特·K·马西（Robert K. Massey）并没有说他是对的，但他认为这是一次
public demonstration of Peter's seriousness about his project. He eliminated the one great obstacle to his modernizing mission, which was the Streltsy, and effectively, yeah, he was right to do it. That it's a terrible thing, but he was right to do it. I mean, I personally don't think publicly beheading people is the way forward. And leaving corpses dangling outside the cell in which you've imprisoned your sister. No, I wouldn't do that. So he ends up disbanding the Streltsy completely the year later in 1699. That leaves him really in a position of absolute power.
公开展示彼得对他的事业的严肃态度。他消除了他现代化使命的一大障碍，那就是斯特列尔齐，实际上，是的，他这样做是对的。虽然这是一件可怕的事情，但他这样做是对的。我的意思是，我个人认为公开斩首人们并不是前进的方向。而且把尸体挂在你囚禁你姐姐的牢房外。不，我不会那样做。所以他最终在第二年，即 1699 年，完全解散了斯特列尔齐。这确实使他处于绝对权力的地位。
And at first, how does he spend that political capital? He actually just has endless parties and feasts. Ah, yeah. How does he spend that political capital? He actually just has endless parties and feasts. Huzzah! Yeah, so there's a lot of like mad costumes, mocking religious rituals. They'll do the sign of the cross with two pipes. Is there bear action? Lots of bears. Bellows. Dwarfs jumping out of pies, all of this kind of thing.
起初，他是如何挥霍这些政治资本的？他实际上只是举办了无休止的派对和宴会。啊，是的。他是如何挥霍这些政治资本的？他实际上只是举办了无休止的派对和宴会。万岁！是的，所以有很多疯狂的服装，嘲弄宗教仪式。他们会用两个烟斗画十字。有熊出没的环节吗？很多熊。风箱。侏儒从馅饼里跳出来，诸如此类的事情。
And Peter often, he'll get incredibly drunk and then he'll have a massive fight with his friends. I mean there's stories of him kind of drawing his sword and attacking his friends. He's very, very hot-tempered. I do urge people to watch The Great if they want to see this on a television screen. Right. But what's on his mind clearly the whole time is this idea that Augustus the Strong had suggested, you know, why don't we have a crack at the Swedes? Why don't we try to carve up the Baltic between us? Now, the thing is, he's still nominally fighting the Ottomans. So he's got to finish that off first. And in July 1700, he agrees a 30 year truce with the Ottomans.
而且彼得经常喝得酩酊大醉，然后跟朋友们大打出手。我的意思是，有关于他拔剑袭击朋友的故事。他的脾气非常非常暴躁。我确实敦促大家如果想在电视屏幕上看到这一点，可以去看看《凯瑟琳大帝》（The Great）。对的。但他脑子里一直清楚在想的，是强者奥古斯特（Augustus the Strong）曾建议过的那个想法，你知道，为什么我们不试着攻击瑞典人呢？为什么我们不试着瓜分波罗的海呢？现在的问题是，他名义上仍在与奥斯曼帝国作战。所以他必须先把这件事情完成。2000 年 7 月，他与奥斯曼帝国达成了一项为期 30 年的停战协议。
Peter will keep his conquest at Azov that we talked about at the beginning of this episode, but he will give up all hope of access to the Black Sea. Because now his eye is on the Baltic. Exactly. So the news of the treaty reaches Moscow on the 18th of August, 1700, and they have a massive fireworks display in celebration and the very next day, the 19th of August, 1700, Peter declares war on Sweden and with that the great northern war begins and for Peter for Russia and for the whole of northern and Eastern Europe the world will never be
彼得将保留我们在本集开头谈到的对亚速的征服，但他将放弃获得黑海通道的所有希望。因为现在他的目光投向了波罗的海。没错。因此，条约的消息于 2000 年 8 月 18 日传到莫斯科，他们举行了盛大的焰火表演来庆祝，紧接着的第二天，即 2000 年 8 月 19 日，彼得向瑞典宣战，大北方战争由此拉开序幕，对于彼得、对于俄罗斯以及整个北部和东欧，世界将永远
the same again. And that is an epic story, written on a massive scale and it will be beginning next week and if you want to hear all of the episodes detailing the Great Northern War and its aftermath then you can sign up at the rest this history.com if you're not already a member of the club and if you don't want to do that then that's fine the episodes will be coming out in due course in the meanwhile Dominic thanks so much some wonderful stories and all that. Beards, corsets, wheelbarrows, it's all been kicking off. Yeah.
不再一样了。这是一个史诗般的故事，规模宏大，将于下周开始。如果你想听到详细介绍大北方战争及其后果的所有剧集，那么如果你还不是俱乐部会员，你可以在 theresaistory.com 注册。如果你不想这样做，那也没关系，剧集会适时推出。与此同时，多米尼克，非常感谢你带来的一些精彩故事和所有这些。胡子、紧身胸衣、独轮车，一切都在进行中。是的。
And as we say, next week, the Great Northern War. So bye bye. Goodbye. I'm David McCloskey, former CIA analyst turned spy novelist. And I'm Gordon Carrera, national security journalist. And together we're the hosts of The Rest is Classified, where we bring you brilliant stories from the world of spies. This week we're talking about one of the most significant stories of the 21st century, Edward Snowden and how he orchestrated the biggest leak of classified secrets in
正如我们所说，下周，大北方战争。所以再见。再见。我是戴维·麦克洛斯基（David McCloskey），前中情局分析师，后转行成为间谍小说家。我是戈登·卡雷拉（Gordon Corera），国家安全记者。我们一起主持《机密档案》（The Rest is Classified），在这里我们为您带来来自间谍世界的精彩故事。本周我们讨论的是 21 世纪最重要的故事之一，爱德华·斯诺登以及他是如何策划了
modern American and British history. Snowden revealed that the American government was mass collecting data on its own citizens and it was really the first time that Americans and so many others around the world understood the extent of the US government's mass surveillance. That's right, it's a story I covered at the time and it also really gets to wider questions about what privacy means, how technology has changed our lives and what the government and companies can do with data we might have thought was private. And we'll take you through the whole story from Snowden's early career in the CIA and
现代美国和英国历史上最大规模机密泄露事件的。斯诺登透露，美国政府一直在大规模收集其自身公民的数据，这确实是美国人和世界各地许多其他人第一次真正了解美国政府大规模监控的程度。没错，这是我当时报道的一个故事，它也真正触及了关于隐私意味着什么、技术如何改变了我们的生活以及政府和公司能对我们原以为是私密的数据做些什么等更广泛的问题。我们将带您了解整个故事，从斯诺登在中情局的早期职业生涯和
the NSA to his life in exile in Russia. So to hear more search for The Rest is Classified wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
国安局（NSA）到他在俄罗斯的流亡生活。因此，想要收听更多内容，请在您获取播客的任何地方搜索《机密档案》。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。